okay I'm going to go ahead and open up
today's hearings that we have scheduled
here in the house education committee I
trust all members of the committee had a
wonderful break and relaxed a little bit
um chair which the chair was down here
four out of the five days but
um it's going to be back in commit here
but we do have some items on the docket
today especially that last bill I want
to speak to it a little bit um at 12:30
we have a bill schedule relative to
standardized assessment data for
participants in the education Freedom
accounts um we will be holding that in
this room however we have two rooms
which are going to receive ex access
excess um people who want to testify and
we'll be doing like we've done before
we'll be you know announcing the person
not the person's on deck and maybe even
the person in the Hole uh so that um we
can have people flow in here if and when
I was speaking with on Friday the folks
that are in charge of Maintenance here
in the building and operations they're
they're sheetrocking down the hall and
we didn't know they were going to be
doing exactly what they've got we knew
they were coming in we thought it was
going to be done over the weekend and
and so what we will do is we'll watch
that and if it becomes too much of a
congestion we'll have to move it to reps
Hall so we'll make that decision as we
get going into the process here and find
how many people show up to testify on
that
bill so that'll be at 12:30 this
afternoon so right now I'd like to back
up to the top to 9:00 where we are with
HB
1608 this is relative to provide
providing an induction program for new
teachers and this is represent Myers
Bill he is not here today um so repon
luno is going to present that bill on
his behalf thank you and welcome thank
you very much Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Dave luno uh
representing the people of Hopkinson and
Bo and folks all across the uh the the
great Granite State and um I'm here this
morning on representative Myers's behalf
to introduce House Bill
16008 uh relative to providing an
induction program for new teachers so I
should start out saying that my
background is in electrical
engineering and so induction has a very
different meaning in that context um and
uh it usually involves very very high
strength magnetic fields or electric
fields and um and so when I first looked
at this bill I'm like oh my gosh what
are we actually planning on doing for
new teachers how could this possibly
possibly be a good thing well turns out
induction has another meaning and and it
it goes more along the lines of
mentorship and um and so what
1608 is about it's it's not applying
high strength electric and magnetic
fields to new teachers it's about
providing them uh a mentor uh as they
get started in um uh in the early stages
of their their career so um so the um
without going through the the the
details of of all the bills and I I
believe um we're going to be able to to
hear uh from Mr Hawkins on um on what
some of these are um uh that uh that
there that there are are many
recommendations that come from the um
the report on that came out of the
teacher shortage study commission and
mentorship was uh was one of those
recommendations and U uh like I said I'm
uh I'm you know I had misunderstood what
the
original intent to this bill is you know
um so so don't ask me too many questions
about mentoring if you want to ask me
questions about um about you know um
magnetic induction and stuff like that
I'm happy to take those but I think Mr
Hawkins could certainly talk about um uh
the recommendations uh along these lines
that came out of the report thank you Mr
chair thank you very much are there any
questions for represent
luno oh my gosh represent
woodcock
good to see you again good morning um
just do you are represent my and I'm
sure maybe has any background on about
how many schools in the state don't have
a program existing for mentorship uh I I
can't speak for representative Miler but
I don't I don't have that information
okay thank you thank CH are there any
other questions so you're not going to
talk about conduction
huh or all temperatures and electricity
no okay about half to so okay represent
cordelli thank you thank you for uh
presenting this um just you might not
know the answer to this but I didn't see
it specifically mentioned but there is a
um A1
thousand um stipended I guess to the uh
to the mentor but I'm not sure where if
that's a state um funded uh stipended or
if it's a locally funded yeah I I'm not
sure specified that's a very good
question thank you I'm not sure that's
specified uh in here I think if this is
going to be a state law then it then you
know I would I would recommend it be a
state-funded um uh
appropriation further questions
representa Tanner thank you and I don't
know if this question is for you or for
the chair but um I'm just curious why
when there's a statement like that in
the in the uh methodology on the
financial notes fiscal note that that
from the Department of Education we're
getting um indeterminable or zero in the
fiscal uh responsibility for local or or
state and yet the methodology goes on to
explain and and kind of take a take a
position I'm just
wondering what why that happens like
that yeah no I think that's I I I I
don't know uh why it happens and um and
you know I I would also suggest that
that the department would probably have
some idea you know in terms of the
number of uh of firste um early career
teachers uh that there are in the state
and multiply that out by $1,000 and that
would be the uh the the sort of ballpark
um uh State obligation so I don't know
why it's why it's
indeterminable further
questions thank uh repent Hall thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um it says on line 29 the doe
shall adopt rules um though is still
this still going to be mostly local
control like who picks the who picks the
mentee or the mentor sorry the mentor m
is as a new person but um is most of the
power going to be local or is it going
to be the doe I I again I'm not sure how
the how the bill reflects on that my my
sort of understanding about how you know
we we've we've done some things in our
school district in the past is that is
that a an early career teacher may be
paired up with uh with a with a a master
teacher or senior more senior teacher um
uh that that already is employed by the
by the district um I can't remember I
don't remember uh if there was a stipend
um that we uh that that that the School
District offered uh to the mentor but I
think in this case what it's saying is
let's let's take that off of the the
shoulders of the of the local and make
it something that that encourages the
local to do by have by making it a state
program further questions from the
committee representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair thank you
representative um line
eight it says an orientation program for
beginning teachers and all other
incoming new teachers to the district is
that the same program or would the
school district have to implement two
different programs perhaps if a teacher
does have experience perhaps Decades of
experience but in a different School
District would they be a part of this
orientation program the way that's
worded yeah that's a that's a good
question I'm I'm I think the orientation
program is really really to sort of uh
introduce teachers that are new to the
school whether they're experienced
teachers or whether they're new to the
to the to the teaching profession um
just sort of how you know introduce them
to the school building introduce them
around to other teachers who are the who
are the people to who are the go-to
people if you've got a question about
this or a question about that that type
of stuff you know further questions
thank you very much great thank you very
much you're welcome we have a card here
you
uh good morning good morning uh thank
you Mr chairman for the record Brian
Hawkins rep representing Nea New
Hampshire um I I'll add just a few
points um f first to say I was not the
author of The Language uh uh for this
bill and so uh just for for context but
we certainly do support the intent of
this as representative luno mentioned
earlier uh this was a topic of
discussion during the the teacher
shortage committee um that this support
early on uh in in the career of a
teacher not only uh new to the career
but new to a school um is particularly
important and it's in those first uh
several years where uh you really have
an idea whether someone is going to be
able to continue on um as as as an
educator um or not uh last year um and I
I think some of the intent of this is
similar to what uh Senate Bill 218 which
is currently on the table in the house
uh uh held and that was you know a
mentorship program that was uh there for
uh Educators in their first few years of
their career or in in a school a couple
of comments I just wanted to uh make on
some of the language um first just there
are schools that do have mentorship
programs um some of those mentorship
programs are collectively bargained and
so um if the committee moves forward
with the bill I think would be important
to um
uh acknowledge and accommodate uh the
fact that there there are already some
of these programs that are in place not
every school um has mentorship program
or or a robust mentorship program I
don't have figures on that but um uh
again the bill that came to you from the
Senate last year the intent there was to
help Foster and grow those programs I
think the same intent um is is here so
there's uh and then finally um and maybe
this was probably better for the
Department to speak to you know the
beginning of the bill they talk about uh
guidelines
um being established by the
department um my understanding is the
department used to have a mentorship
program within the department but uh I
am not sure where that is at uh
currently and so we would obviously want
the resources to be there to be able to
support this type of program to make
sure successful so uh with that I'll
close my testimony I'm happy to take any
questions are there any questions of Mr
Hawkins yes represent Damon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
would you have any information on the
impact of mentorship programs on teacher
retention uh yes um there I I would be
happy to supply the committee with some
of that uh I can tell you
anecdotally um I do know educators who
uh made decisions on where to be a
teacher uh based on the fact that a
school district had a robust mentorship
program e even though they may have uh
made just a little bit less money um
knowing that they had uh the support
going into especially you know as I said
for uh a brand new educator um you know
that's worth worth its weight in gold so
yeah yes further yes represent cascaden
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm not sure if um if you
would have this um information but I'm
questioning uh title two funds which
schools get who are designed for
professional
development and at one point I can't
remember if it was in the last
session um we we may have had a
conversation about um teacher mentorship
and
induction and there might have been an
issue and I I think there's somebody
here from the Department where districts
may have to expend their title two funds
before they can access these funds or is
there no relationship between the two or
between the two do you know uh that
that's a good question I do recall that
conversation in in the bill I mentioned
earlier that was on the table I I did
notice that in the Department's fiscal
note I think they referenced
to unless I'm I'm thinking of another
bill but um that would be a good
question for the Department I'm I'm
sorry thanks that's all right yeah yeah
further questions yes represent W thank
you chairman good morning good to see
you again good morning welcome back um
the same question I asked representative
luno uh in New Hampshire do you have any
idea how many schools don't have some
type of orientation or mentorship
program uh I I don't have a an exact
figure for you I'm sorry um I don't
think it's something that is tracked to
my knowledge um either by the department
uh other than you know sort of going
School District by School District to
see if they have either have a policy or
something in a in a contract that
indicates that but I know that it's not
all schools so in essence the the
responsibility currently is dependent
upon the local school district if they
choose to provide a program program
that' be correct there's no law that
requires that that this would uh
supplement or or plant not not to my
knowledge um and and for uh many school
districts it's a it's a resource uh
decision you know I mean okay having to
decide between do I uh you know allocate
money toward this program when I was at
uh uh involved with the state employees
you know
we had a conversation in in finance one
year about how training and that that
sort of those were some of the first
things to always get cut the budget
process so thank you thank you chairman
further further
questions thank you very much all right
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to hear
McLean good morning good morning uh my
name is Mark mlan first of all thank you
uh chairman thank you uh committee for
letting me come to the microphone my
name is Mark mlan I represent the New
Hampshire school administrators
Association um essentially I'm just here
in case there are any questions I can
tell you that when I was a
superintendent the districts that I was
in had a robust Mentor program in fact
it was a two-year Mentor program for
brand new teachers and for teachers who
were new to the district it was really
just suited based on what their needs
were um they were beholding to it for
one year but was differentiated based on
their needs and I can tell you that in
marac Valley 50% of the salary for the
2A are there followup questions for Mr
mlan uh I will note to the the committee
members here we did have a teacher
shortage committee which me was it last
summer I'm it's all meshing together um
and some of the recommendations which
are in that report are worthy of our
looking at here I'm looking at one right
now uh invest in robust teacher
mentoring programs and opportunities for
professional learning and that's what
this is all about right here so if we
look at that report we might be able to
see where that study ended up um so I'll
try and get a copy of that make it
available for all people on the
committee here are there representative
Tanner thank you thank you for taking my
question could you uh kind of um explain
a little bit how cultures differ from
school to school and how uh orientation
to those cultures and demographics is
really important for an incoming teacher
whether they're experienced or not sure
um first of all there's a lot to learn
just about local processes everything
from uh the acronyms that are being used
when it comes to which meetings you're
going to to just really understanding
the building and the culture and clim of
that particular Learning Community um
essentially what I've seen in my
experience is that Mentor programs will
reign from someone who just said here's
an experienced person in your department
they will meet with you kind of
informally to make sure that you have
the sports you need to a coaching
program where there is essentially a
curriculum where you're really working
with the teacher uh to ensure that
they're getting what they need and as
others before me have mentioned there is
a lot of evidence and I don't know those
off the top of my head but there there
is research out there about the impact
of a mentor program on teachers staying
and teachers feeling as though they
belong in their Learning Community um I
would also add that uh there are some
great teacher mentors around the state
that if you wanted to learn more about
Mentor programs it'd be great to hear
from and uh when I was in marac Valley
what we did is we had a new teacher
orientation program and um we brought
all the new teachers together we uh
really tried to play up the fact that
they were the class of whatever class
they were coming in in as say
2022 um there would be t-shirts there
would be pictures it'd be a signing
ceremony it was almost like when a a
college player uh or when a high school
player is choosing their college so
essentially we really tried to play up
the fact that they were choosing marac
Valley and um it was it was powerful and
throughout the year we would meet with
teachers um and we would uh the the
assistant superintendent myself would go
uh meet with them bring them a hot cup
of coffee ask them how it was going and
it was typically during December or
January when the days started growing
shorter and perhaps folks are
questioning their sanity just a little
bit because they're driving to work in
the dark and leaving in the dark and
really just to make sure that folks are
getting what they need do they have all
the supports in place and then we would
interview people and ask them whether or
not it was meeting their needs and we
would really learn about the mentor
program and what teachers needed and it
was really really beneficial and it does
impact
turnover the the program we're talking
about um there were a number of uh
aspects to it there was h a teacher loan
forgiveness portion of this there was uh
teacher preparation
institutions like you University of New
Hampshire keen and Plymouth are they
preparing properly for these people to
come into our schools and also the
mentoring program for new teachers and
it also was discussing for those
teachers that might be moving into a
district from another District um and
that's a little bit different though
than you know the brand new teacher and
how we use the title two Monies to work
in and mesh with this uh so Mark you
said you did not have any idea how many
districts are using title 2 for this
purp yeah I don't know and I don't know
if the department is tracking that
information I think it's an interesting
question and I see that um might be
looking for that answer right now I'm
not sure typing feverishly back there um
so uh you know again I would reference
just that it depends on how districts
are leveraging that whether or not
they're spreading the mentorship program
amongst a lot of personnel or whether
they have a teacher mentor on staff who
essentially has a case load of new
teachers every single year and the touch
points are different with people based
on what their needs are and as you just
referenced whether or not they're coming
from uh as an experienced teacher from a
different District their needs are
different and uh whether or not there a
brand new teacher coming from a teacher
training program their needs are also
going to be different so um you know I
think it's difficult and as
representative Ludo luno alluded to um I
think you know funding this is extremely
important and as it stands right now I
think people are funding it differently
whether it's part of collective
bargaining as uh Mr Hawkins talked about
or whether it's part of uh title 2A or
whether it's just um you know something
that that folks are doing as like an
extra stien for teachers and it just
comes from the general budget so I think
there are a variety of ways that folks
are funding it right now but to do it
right um just like everything uh takes
some
resources yes represent
Tanner yes um thank you is there a
similar program for
administrators that's a great question
and I thought about that as I was
walking up um I think it's typically
incumbent upon the leadership team to do
that so in my experience it's been much
more informal but it is similar uh it
has not been a stipended position in my
experience uh that said it doesn't mean
it doesn't have to be and um you know I
I again I think it's part of the
leadership culture and the leadership
team that you or that someone uh is
joining so it's certainly important and
also for support staff there are
mentorship uh program out there as well
and uh the New Hampshire school
administrators Association
is designing right now in partial
collaboration with the Department a
mentor program that will support
incoming system leaders and we recognize
that as being a really important aspect
to success a really important aspect to
folks learning the New Hampshire way and
could be connected to lcen chair and
other
aspects is there a problem Mark with
this that we have many property poor
communities that are training teachers
they get them trained they get them
mentored and bingo they're gone the next
year to the ab budding District which is
paying $10,000 more per year is that a
issue that we need to also address well
it's certainly an issue um and again I
think uh anybody here has read the book
by Daniel pink called drive or heard of
it um talks about motivation and what
actually
uh people who have high cognition in
their jobs and are making a lot of
decisions what brings them actualization
and fulfillment in work it's not always
money but money is part of it so I think
if we can work together and there are
programs that actually support teachers
teachers have voice and agency in their
jobs they're going to find a lot of
actualization and as uh Mr Hawkins
alluded to sometimes folks will stay in
a district where they make less money
but they have more professional
fulfillment and feel as though their
impact is something that they can
continue with and they can continue to
grow I can tell you that I taught in
Newport for my first two years and then
I moved to marac Valley so um you know
sometimes that does happen but sometimes
it's also based on geographic location
as well thank you are there any other
questions thank thank you very much
you're welcome uh does the department
have any information for us on this on
title
good morning Melissa white division
director for learner Support Department
of Education um I have uh some estimates
on the past three years the amount of
title 2 funding that was utilized to
support mentorship and induction
programs in the state of New Hampshire
that is at about 2.9 Million so roughly
a million per per year is being utilized
out of the title 2 funds for these
programs across the state I was trying
to get the exact number of leas and I'm
working on getting that um but I don't
have that number off um with me right
now the proposed legislation I just want
to be clear
would violate section 222g of the esa
Elementary and secondary Education Act
of 1965 regarding supplement versus
supplanting so if the state does decide
to move forward with this legislation
it's just important that we recognize
then title 2 or other federal funds
could not be utilized for this
particular work we would have to utilize
state and local funds to support this
the reason why the um fiscal note showed
indeterminable because we don't have the
exact number of new teachers because I
think the proposed legislation does have
a component in there about have three
years of
experience in the first initial three
years of teaching but it also could be
new in New in that uh content area I
think that was another piece of it that
might have been the the first iteration
of of this proposed legislation so not
having those numbers on how many
teachers we couldn't give a exact
estimate but we're looking at you know
the ,000 for the stien depending on the
number of teachers that you know that
would cover um in addition to I think
each district Works a little bit
differently but if you're looking at
classroom observation
time there there's costs associated with
substitutes and that type of thing so
it's just to consider it could impact
different schools in different ways as
far as how they would support this work
so that's why we had that that piece in
there that we just couldn't give you an
exact number but I mean it could be zero
but it could ALS so be a little bit more
when you're looking at some of the
schools that do have large numbers of um
new teachers they tend to have pretty
robust um mentorship programs I can
think of a a few pretty pretty great
districts in our state that that have
those strong programs thank you
represent
dry thank you and thank you for taking
the question do you know how many school
districts do uh MERS ship as part of
collective bargaining that I don't know
okay thank you sorry represent Tanner
thank you um I you went through why
federal funds couldn't be used for this
and I didn't quite catch the whole thing
could could you kind of slow that down
and and explain what part of the federal
uh regulations prohibit use of this for
mentoring and also and tagging into that
so you can include it can local funds be
used after the federal funds have been
expended
thank you for the question so with the
supplement versus supplant that is um a
little bit tricky with the federal funds
because if the state passes a law making
a requirement then it's the state's
responsibility to cover whatever cost
would be associated with that
requirement so if you have a certain
requirement you cannot use your federal
funds to then pay for that state
mandated requirement so with the
the federal funds in addition to title
two we're looking at idea is another
huge chunk I didn't get the figures for
that one but idea funds are used for the
special education uh new teacher
induction programs and mentorship
programs in addition to the um special
education administrators any new
administrators in special education um
the state has a contract where we um
provide a program for all of those new
administrators to support them in their
first couple of years of uh in their
position as administrators but schools
do also use those funds then to support
the the um new special education
teachers whether they're new to special
education altogether or a new teacher
and new to special education so that
that's another uh
consideration it would be challenging to
track expending all of our funds
Statewide and then to just say okay
we've spent all our funds now we can you
know tap into the federal funds if it's
a it's a mandate it it
gets um it it could be contested by by
the feds if they were looking into
it are all your federal funds title 2
used each year uh I know the last time
you were here we heard about title 2 and
how some districts still have
money over here what happens if there's
a surplus or a balance left in that
particular account at the end of that
period in which the money should be
expended it's returned to the feds it's
returned are we returning money to the
feds
yes I wouldn't say it's a large balance
but yes we do return funds and I can get
those figures to if you want to take a
look at how much in the title two funds
were returning each year represent Damon
state level funds we tend to spend down
completely so we do get a state level
set aside portion for our work at the
state level and that's what we utilize
for um one of the programs we offer
right now is through um oh it's not 321
Insight uh teach United it's a program
that goes into some of our more rural
schools and school districts and does um
a mentorship support program but it
makes it um really beneficial because
they're able to tap into um teachers
across that different um regions so they
may not all be from the same school but
if you have one new teacher here one new
teacher here one new teacher here it
creates kind of a community and a
collaborative with that particular work
so we don't have a Statewide mentorship
program but we do have smaller programs
that we're tapping into and offering
across the state with these
organizations nhli is another one that
that is looking at doing some work with
us um to specifically
so we do have programming focused on
this but um I
think looking back at perhaps some of
the work that we did in the past and
having that
Statewide initiative might might be
beneficial thank you representa Tanner
thank you just as a followup to that so
my understanding from what you just said
is that the federal funds come to the
State Department of Education and that
to a large extent you are the people
that prescribe
the me the mentorship or what what can
happen in the different schools for um
staff development so when we're talking
about an induction program such as this
um could this could the Department of
Education take this particular outline
from the commission and actually set up
a program that would be federally funded
uh rather than uh force it on to the
local school districts
as long as we didn't stick it in
legislation excuse me as long as we
didn't put it in legislation once it
goes into law then it's a state so how
do we how do we get it into the doe
rather than put it through
um it could be a little bit tricky
because if it goes into legislation then
it is a state law but if we're looking
at doing initi an initiative outside of
that then it would just be something
that we work
on I kind of outside
of outside of this room represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I actually have
two questions please so the first is I'm
not sure if I understood correctly but I
think a few minutes ago you indicated
that the title two funds that the state
receives need to be entirely spent
before local can step in so it's not
that the title two funds are distributed
to different districts and the district
could expend their title two and then
local step in it's the whole state um
yes correct pool is that correct which
is I think 11 million and that's why you
said it would be hard to track because
correct especially if we're returning
funds each
year and the other question is
the 2.9 million plus that you referenced
and is in the more recent fiscal note
that we got that is currently funding
some mentoring for new teachers and
administrators do we have any breakdown
of how many districts are utilizing that
or what gaps there are in other words
how adequate or not is the existing
resources I don't have that information
to provide to you but I can give that to
you and send it in a followup but we do
we are able to look at some of those and
with one of the programs I mentioned the
teach United We in fact do that we look
at okay they're utilizing their funds um
for all of these purposes with title 2
so here we you know they could benefit
from being involved in this program that
that does this induction and and this
support um for the new teachers but it's
really the district um uh stepping up
and and taking that initiative saying
they want to be a part of it so we're
not requiring it of them that something
that they're reaching out saying yes we
do want to be a part of this and then so
we do pro provide that indu ction in
mentorship is incredibly important
Studies have shown that teachers that do
have that mentorship um and I think it
is a three years that a lot of the
studies have looked at it might be up to
five years but retention they they do
see all the studies across the board
have shown teachers tend to stick in the
field past of five years if they're
involved in a high quality in induction
program thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question um you mentioned that
unused funds are sent back to the
federal government so are you not as a
as a department re Distributing
funds we we cannot take the funds and
redistribute them be because they have
until the ending of that date so if it's
September 30th is usually our deadlines
so September 30th of 23 the schools Can
U have until until them to utilize their
funds so then we see okay after
September 30th or you know 45 days of
closing who didn't utilize all their
funds that funding period that period of
performance has already ended so we
couldn't then take the funds and
redistribute we are now looking at um
currently for our following uh year for
2425 we're establishing an application
system so that schools can then say okay
we intend to spend down this amount of
funds and then we will be able to take
that Remer and redistribute but the way
that we've been uh structured in the
past if they had until September 30th
and they'd have to indicate prior to
that that they weren't going to so that
we could redistribute it according to
the formula so it couldn't just be like
oh okay this school district is you know
is not going to utilize all their funds
so we're just going to give it to this
one it has to be by the formula so it
would have to go out to all of the
school other school districts evenly
according to the the the formula follow
up yes um so just to clarify in my mind
because I'm familiar with redistribution
of funds is it that you need to go out
to the district say in the springtime to
see what funds are you not going to use
moving forward or what activities have
not been planned yet and that pool of
money is then looked at and
redistributed and I know there's a short
window of time to expend that yes but
most of the time they do say they're
going to utilize it all and if we look
at you know a little bit here a little
bit here a little bit here collectively
it does end up you know
being a good uh amount of funding that
could be utilized but at that point it's
you know past the date and not many are
willing to say in April no I'm not going
to spend down my entire funds we don't
see that too much okay but we we work
with them to try to U utilize the funds
and expend it and sometimes you know
they have good intentions of spending
down the funds but then
maybe something falls through or a
program do you know they anticipated um
doing a specific uh event or whatever it
might be training and then it falls
through that I mean that does happen
talk withu
orientation and the doe is currently
very supportive of that under the title
of funding is there a reason that Doe as
an entity hasn't required all schools or
have they put technal advis saying these
are these are mod lead programs that we
fund so we understand the connection
between your attention and teach the
success something we do Statewide deal
don't do every school do so we do offer
model activities but the funding really
is locally needs to be determined
because they need to do A needs
assessment and analyze what you know
what their priorities are so if they're
seeing you know there are school
districts that look and say we have a
very strong need for a mentorship and
induction program we are going to focus
our funds on this after doing their
needs assessment there might be others
that don't have a different need and so
they prioritize the funds in a different
way but it really is up to the local
level we provide model activities and we
can make suggestions but we can't
require them to use it for a certain
purpose because that is you know it is
their funds to determine to use how they
see fit thank you thank you Mr chair
you're welcome representative cascan you
had a followup question but we could
prioritize our state level funds more
towards that if the state decided that
were a priority and I think that's you
know looking to the past to see what
we've done in the past and then planning
for the future of how we want to move
forward and and perhaps do more of the
state level
that yeah go thank you so on that point
Thank you Mr chairman so on that point
does the when you when you said the
state could prioritize doeses that mean
the commissioner or the commissioner's
leadership staff could prioritize this
is where we think uh title two money
should be invested first um correct okay
thank you thank chair repr scen I think
I had my thank you my question was along
the same lines so the federal funds come
to the department and then they're
distributed by the
titles and
the department I believe can take some
of that titled two-way money whether
they're paying for staff or I I don't
know what other guidelines they have but
could um the state
program from title 2A to meet that
criteria sure of before it distributes
its funds to the districts no so we are
provided a state level set aside and an
administrative set aside so there's this
very tiny tiny percentage that is um for
administrative costs and that's to uh
fund uh one staff person to operate the
the title 2 program then there's the
state level set aside portion within the
state level set aside portion there's a
chunk that is for administrators and uh
building leaders principles and so we
utilize those funds for nhsaa we utilize
it for for um the School principes
Association here in New Hampshire um
they offer specific events and trainings
and opportuni so we put our funding
towards that our state level um funding
towards that in addition to programs
like teach United that is doing more of
the rural supports for the teachers we
try to be creative and utilize our title
three funds to support um teacher
training and that's the state level
title 3 funds uh teacher trainings for
our um El
Educators the special education Ida
funds we try to focus that BEC so it's
like if we can find a specific content
area or um specialist supports we
utilize those funds um but the title two
funds then we look at doing some other
programs um in hli we do several
programs with them so it it just varies
in in what what we do each year but we
have that all on our website what we
utilize the funds for when Distributing
your title 2 monies out to the districts
is it done based upon a weighted value
of the number of students maybe you have
within that District or is it based upon
poverty within that District uh ability
to raise the dollars or uh any other
methodology and as we do with the public
school infrastructure monies and have
done that with some of the Gopher monies
as well that we've approved up to so
much per District some districts are
capped and that's what they receive but
if we have money returned then it's
reauthorized to those districts which
have gone beyond their cap um is is
anything like that available in title to
no so the uh Federal um US Department of
Education they determine the allocations
for title 2 a so they'll look at the
numbers they have the formula they make
the determination they hand us a piece
of paper that says this is what each
district gets and here's the amount with
the um with that then we have to provide
the funding based on that again if
there's any funding let's say we were to
you know take collectively a bunch of
leftover funds and try to redistribute
it it has to be according to that
formula we couldn't say prioritize
somebody else with that funding the the
the funds that are specified for the
leas have to follow that specific
formula we can't change that at all
thank you further questions not seeing
thank you very much thank you and any
information you can get back to us on
this be
appreciated I have no more pink cards on
this bill so we're going to close this
hearing and move on to the next one
have
M could you fill out a pink card for us
and then we'll just use that as
technical
you okay next Bild is
last okay we're on to the next bill this
is
hp605 it's relative to alternative
education programs for granting credit
leading to graduation representa GI
welcome thank you Mr chairman and thank
you committee for having me uh so this
bill uh is is pretty straightforward uh
with a lot of EFA funds being approved
we want to make sure that we're doing
the right thing by uh the way the
students so we want to make sure
that uh that our our students with
disabilities are not being overlooked
and that we're in compliance with other
state and federal laws so what this bill
says is that what we would be adding to
the language is a for-profit or
nonprofit entity that offers an
education program approved under this
section shall comply with all state and
federal anti-discrimination laws the
State Board of Education shall annually
review all entities that offer an
educational program approved under this
section for continued compliance with
all state and federal
anti-discrimination laws entities found
in non-compliance shall be referred to
the Human Rights Commission um you're
probably very well familiar with state
and federal uh anti-discrimination laws
but just view New Hampshire Department
of Education does not discriminate on
the basis of age color disability
national origin race religion sex gender
identity
sexual orientation veteran status or any
other category protected by applicable
law in access to treatment and and
employment um in any of its uh programs
or
activities uh so that is and I'm getting
that from the Department of education's
website uh and then the
federal laws are actually a little bit
um
the
non-discrimination uh statement it it
said
everything mostly everything that I'm
just trying to find the exact link that
I had pulled up earlier and and it
disappeared on me but um basically it
has to be ADA Compliant so
uh that's essentially it do you have any
questions thank you very much are there
any reps in McDonald thank you Mr chair
thank you representative um do you know
of any entities within New Hampshire
that are offering educational
programs approved under the section that
are not in compliance with the law yes I
do um so prageru was approved uh to be
under and the New Hampshire Department
of Education approved them over the
summer but they discriminate based on
religion so we would not be able to if
they're not going to be in compliance
with state and federal laws then they
would not be able to get educational
funds and to be fair um if we Circle
back to that the particular program that
was approved was a financial
literacy um course and that is offered
through Con Academy online for free and
it is in compliance with the um state
and federal uh anti-discrimination laws
so we could not only provide uh students
with a financial literacy course but
also do it for free and also do it in
compliance with all of the
anti-discrimination laws may I have a
follow-up question yes you may was the
prageru course that you mentioned what
inspired you to put forward this
legislation or was there something else
uh I'm I've always been an advocate for
the disabled community
so uh this is basically getting us in
compliance with laws that are already
out there like federal laws
representative cordelli and then
represent beler um thank you um just
wondering about um the prageru uh
financial literacy program how is how is
that
program um being made available uh how
is that discriminated against um any
particular um
population it's in their um they they're
a they're a religious organization so
unless they're going to accept students
of all religions and not discuss
religion at all in their curriculum then
they would be out of compliance follow
follow yes how is the financial literacy
program uh discriminating against any
religion um when it comes to financial
literacy so I would have to watch all of
the videos to see if they're mentioning
religion at all but the point is if they
aren't mentioning religion then it would
be okay if they are mentioning religion
it would be out of
compliance but we could go to KH Academy
which is free and is
accredited it's accredited through the
laws School admission Council if for
elsat uh preparation it also provides um
K through2 education online for
homeschoolers it also provides MCAT
education for people trying to go to
medical school so so Con Academy is
really
uh a well it has a a good foundation uh
and it's free and it has a federal uh
excuse me a financial literacy course on
there as
well so there's just not a need to
utilize something that discriminates if
we have a
different but we don't know that it
discriminates you you said you didn't
know because you haven't watched the
course if religion is mentioned isn't
that correct so I haven't watched it in
its entirety right but I do know that
the the
prageru
organization has a religious stance but
how would that violate our
discrimination laws if this course is
being made available and the course does
not mention religion how is that the
providing of that um course
by the State Department of Education
so thank you for your question um I
didn't s state that they don't State
religion what I stated was that I
haven't watched it in its entirety so we
can't confirm nor deny that they don't
mention
religion um the but we do know that the
organization as a whole has a religious
stance and federal fund shouldn't be
going to a religious organization unless
they are in compliance with the fact
that they're not going to teach religion
or that they're going to teach all
religions
equally represent
belard thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for taking my question because it
looks to me that this bill would
implicate at least a couple Supreme
Court cases so I'm looking at the
Supreme Court decision of 2012 in the
Evangelical Lutheran Church and School
versus the Equal Opportunity uh
commission that created the magisterial
exception that said religious
organizations do not um the government
cannot cause them to uh be affected by
anti-discrimination laws because they
have statements of faith that by via the
First Amendment via the First Amendment
supersede anti-discrimination law and
then more
recently uh the Carson versus making
decision Supreme Court said that that um
you cannot prohibit public funds from
from flowing to religious-based
schools um if those funds are to be
offered uh to parents at all to allow
them to pursue their own educational
opportunities for their children um so I
my question is is this is this bill um
seeking to nullify these Supreme Court
decisions and either cause
religious-based schools in New Hampshire
to have to violate their uh statements
of Faith or to shut
down um thank you for your question and
sorry that this speaker
is in between us um what I know that the
bill States is that we need to be in
compliance with
State um Ada recommendations and I read
off what they said so not to
discriminate based on religion so a
lawyer for the uh for the Department of
Education could answer that
further um but I read off what the
Department of Education has on their
website if I may just to clarify a
little further on that answer so you're
you're saying then that that the point
of this bill is not to require the the
closure of religious schools receiving
public funds according to the Supreme
Court decisions so they would have to be
in
compliance with so if they're going to
teach financial literacy for example
then they need to maintain their
language being neutral about religions
so they don't teach
religion so I have not reviewed their
courses in their entirety to know if
they never mention religion so if they
don't mention religion then it would be
in compliance if they do mention
religion that's a problem so that's
that's just a clar further I'm not I'm
not talking about prayer you I'm talking
about religious schools in this state
that are receiving EFA funds from
students who are pursuing them would
those schools have to close as a result
of this
bill I don't believe that they would
have to close as a result of this bill
but I believe that a lawyer for the
Department of Education would be able to
answer this
further are there further questions
represent Tanner thank you um I'm
wondering about the Ada
compliances so um a school that's uh
approved for tuition purposes I don't
think has to have uh for example a
wheelchair ramp um built for a Disabled
Student to come to their school um would
this in fact uh require schools that
receive money and again the EFA is
optional uh the state is giving money to
these to to this program um would they
have to comply with
Ada um wheelchair ramps elevators they
would would have to be in compliance
with the Ada recommendations yes thank
you on the federal level and the state
level yes further
questions thank you very much do we have
any other pink cards on this
around
it's good good school to have
kale thank you Mr chairman uh it's
always good to see you guys I sit in on
your committee all the time I'm always
here to learn uh normally I don't I
don't speak I'm here to learn and and
study what's going on here um I think
you guys have an very important
committee at our state house but what I
just heard a few minutes ago deeply
Disturbed me and I'm going to say
something about it we had we had
representative McDonald ask if there was
any proof of of violation of those rules
in the state and we had someone say
yes and there is no proof of any
violation by Prager
You by her own words she hasn't even
watched all of their programs and I
think it's disturbing that that she
would chair um what what's your
question um just just with with regards
to referencing an earlier um somebody
else's testimony uh the earlier
testimony that's that's their purview
and I think the person speaking now
everybody's allowed to have their own
position their own testimony we all
agree on that uh but to speak in an
opposition to something there's no
problem with that um just don't mention
the prior person just keep well I I
think it was deeply disturbing and
unethical and uh I just wanted to put
that on the record any further questions
representative Woodcock do you want to
take representative K do you want to
take any questions yeah I'll take
question represent Woodcock thank you uh
kale bypassing the specific uh item or
the uh the earlier representative noted
the bigger picture of this Bill section
one would you agree that Federal
anti-discrimination and
anti-discrimination laws are are a
viable part of democracy 100% yeah
absolutely that's all thanks yeah any
other questions thank you very much are
there any other pink cards for this bill
just
represent thank you for the record I am
Lauren cig I represent the town of
Durham which is straford County District
10 and I am in support of this bill um
which specifically has to do with
ensuring that um organizations receiving
our State dollars are not violating our
federal and state anti-discrimination
laws um so uh to answer a question that
was asked previously would this cause
private religious schools to close no
they should continue to receive private
dollars from their private um uh
enrolled students but that doesn't mean
that they should be eligible to receive
our public funds for their religious
education just as I'm sure many of you
would not want to be um forced to endure
uh Ultra Orthodox religious Jewish
Education as some of my family members
endured um and other people would not
wish to endure uh Ultra Catholic or
Ultra Christian or Ultra Muslim or Ultra
bahi or Ultra any other religious
education if it didn't meet their needs
it also doesn't mean that we should be
funding through public dollars those
types of private religious organizations
um but furthermore in terms of
anti-discrimination it's not just based
on religion um a number of these
organizations discriminate People based
on their Identity or based on their
gender and um I know that it is crucial
that we make sure that we are honoring
all of our children and protecting all
of our children and using our public
to ensure that all children in our state
are receiving an education appropriately
to them thank you very much represent s
do you know of any uh for-profit or
nonprofit entities that are receiving
public dollars that are discriminating
um I I I have not taken the time to do
specific research about this bill I just
was responding to the questions
previously I know that when my now high
school graduate was um looking at and
applying to private schools we toward uh
private religious schools that were not
of our faith um and she was
fundamentally told well you can come
here but you're not going to be allowed
to do things the way you like or the way
you think you should and was told
fundamentally that um her religion was
wrong completely um not that they were a
welcoming space and I would not
therefore have submitted my private
dollars to them and would certainly hope
that our public dollars weren't going
there either thank you uh represent
cordelli and then represent belon thank
you I just wondering about your opinion
um on this because um we've heard
testimony about um private excuse me
you're not you've already had testimony
representative G you're not supposed to
be sitting at that
chair um testimony about um students um
with EFA accounts um going to private
religious schools but this isn't a
different section of law this is not
under the education Freedom account
program which is uh RSA
194 so I'm just wondering how does this
apply to that because this is talking
about um credits for
graduation uh from a a public school it
it seems to me so I'm not sure how this
applies to um uh funds um from parents
going to an uh to a school um based on
um my understanding is that this is
about granting credit leading to
graduation and any place that leads to
credit for graduation whether it's
full-time or part-time um would would
fit under that as in my understanding
but again I'm I'm not an attorney and I
don't play one on TV thank you thank you
represent Bel thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here to take this
question which is again again it goes to
the idea of this particularly the
Supreme Court case Carson versus makan
out of 2022 where the Supreme Court
specifically said because they struck
down a main provision that would seem to
be very similar to this law that said
you cannot
utilize um public funds toward any sort
of religious education but the Supreme
Court said you can't do that you have to
if you're going to allow any public
funds to be utilized by parents toward
any type of education you cannot exclude
religious organizations and religious
organizations cannot be subject to
non-discrimination law so is is the
point of this bill in your your mind to
nullify this Supreme Court decision from
2022 I I would never presume to um
nullify a Supreme Court
leus since this would apply to any
organization that
gives that a child can use to get
credit would an organization that the
parent paid for that was Private that
parent paid for their own
money still have to follow this I mean
that's not public money at all oh again
I didn't draft the bill and I'm I'm
speaking about what I heard and I'm
speaking about the content of what I've
read in the bill and so my understanding
and my belief is that we shouldn't be
providing any public funds to any
organization that that does that
um whether someone privately wants to do
that I I don't know how that relates to
this bill I can't answer your question
further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much thank
you represent given you've had your
opportunity do you have a followup I do
um so to answer your question if there
is no public funds going to the organiz
to the school the
organization um then no they don't need
to then that coincides with the Supreme
Court decision where they don't have to
be subject to these the these new laws
it's when there's Public Funding going
into it that they end up having to be in
compliance with the um the laws as
they're written uh the other thing I
just want to throw out there is that I'm
not against P private schools first of
all I sent my older son to dairyfield
and he graduated there from there last
year here and my younger son is
currently in a charter school so I'm not
I'm not
against private schools as a whole I
just am advocating for um students with
any kind of disability or that are
discriminated against in any fashion
thank you very much we're gonna I follow
up no represent Pentel thank you and
thank you for taking my question you
said you send your son to a charter
school is that a private school no
Charter in the state is public
um but they do fall under different
rules and guidelines than the rest of
the um Public Schools so I'm I'm
definitely an advocate for for parents
meeting the needs of their children they
the parents know their child best and
they know
what their child needs as far as the
education there are different forms of
Education that are out there for
different students which is great
to be honest but if we're using public
funds they need to be in compliance with
federal and state laws I mean this is
this is really straightforward so
represent
leus can you show me where it limits
this to public funds because I see no
reference to public funds let me just
quick
oh I see what you're I see what you're
saying um if you would like or if the
committee would want me to put in an an
amendment to make that a little bit more
clear then I can do that I'm happy to do
that or since it's in the committee's
hand now um you guys could do that I
guess thank you represent dry thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um can you help me out if if
a school takes one student with public
funds now are they El obliged to do it
all right no matter how what the
population is of the school correct okay
further
questions that was the point of the the
bill if the wording was a little bit off
then we can fix that with an amendment
Horgan pardon
me
this is yeah we're on 16005 and you have
a pink card in 16005 y well that's
right I just wanted to very quickly uh
agree with those who've advocated for
1605 I don't think this would uh put
religious schools out of business um
there
is regardless even if they you know
launder the money or don't accept direct
funding if we do
allow um any organization into you know
this uh to be have their content Beed
for adequate education that we are at
least uh someone doing State subsidies
so I think um we have the right and even
the duty to uh enforce
anti-discrimination laws and we seem to
be talking about religion just because a
school or any other group calls itself a
religion doesn't um doesn't give it the
right to uh doesn't give it the right to
discriminate and actually um getting
involved these programs may not be good
for a lot of the religious groups
because then you know they are
subjecting themselves to State uh
regulations so you know there I usually
think of the uh Federal First Amendment
more as a separation served it came to
my Judiciary Committee on an issue I
don't want to go to details of which
isue was but one that turns up in
several committees and he said you know
the I mean he gave us somewhat a
strongman version of what the left's
position on the issue is and said this
is a religion for them so I um thought I
was being very smart
um asked him asked him a question you
know like does that mean that
this what what the left position is that
protect protected by the First Amendment
he said no no no the there's he admitted
there's limits to in that case he said
you know that doesn't give it a right to
abuse children so that's um so I think
this bill protects both the taxpayers
and the religious schools and any other
organization wants to participate in
this program so I think this is a good
bill so thank you are there any
questions from the committee
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair good morning representative thanks
for being back in education line 11 of
the bill says the entities and
non-compliance shall be referred to the
Human Rights Commission do you believe
that that might be a bit of a stretch in
violation of this law or is that the
appropriate place to refer someone to um
it could be if someone feels strongly
enough um we've actually over in
judiciary we've been um dealing with the
law and then also just the policies and
how to run the human rights commission
and um so it uh you know it's it's far
from perfect but uh it does work
sometime and actually they do um have a
policy of trying to solve things you
know make the Agri parties uh come to an
agreement um amongst themselves rather
than going through the whole hearing
process so that's um I I don't think the
human rights Human Rights Commission is
not terrible but I think it's uh may not
there maybe some some cases where that's
appropriate if it's an extreme case so
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee no see
thank you very much and with that we're
going to close down the hearing for
6:05 and we'll start our next hearing up
at
10:30
okay we're going to go ahead with the
next bill on the docket for today this
is HB
1592 this bill is relative to the use of
Education Freedom account funds in
religious schools representative Horgan
the prime sponsor of the bill is here
repr
organ thank you and I think I well my
name was announ you all know who
everybody here knows who I am anyway but
just for the record I'm represent
Timothy Horgan I represent straford
County District 10 which is the uh town
of Durham so I'm here to introduce HB
1592 FNL I'm printing around I'm passing
around copies of my printed testimony
which I also emailed to the committee
and put on the portal on the website so
all of you've seen it at least I'm sure
you've all like already read it twice
and absorbed everything in it but I'll
go ahead and speak to you anyway and I
um so
it's a relative to the use of Education
Freedom
accounts in religious schools and it's
basically trying to ban it which I know
is not not exactly universally popular
idea there's not counting the last
section with the effective date which
would be July 1st
2024 um it would be uh yeah there's
three sections actually I'll just skip
very quickly had to section two because
there two things which aren't as
controversial as
section um
section two is the part about the
funding religious goals that's the most
controversial part I haven't gotten any
emails about it apparently you're
getting bombarded with emails and phone
calls about it
um I can emphasize I'm there's a couple
bills over in judiciary that we're
getting bombarded with but um so just
skipping very quickly ahead to the to
the last paragraph of my testimony uh
section one stipulates the higher
education institutions receiving um I'll
call them EFA funds education Freedom
count for school vouchers depending on
which term you prefer to use um anyways
say higher education institutes would
have to be accredited
and the two relevant available reports
on who the vendors are that are
receiving these funds and they're both
as of 20 end of 2022 so they're kind of
outdated and they're not uh they're not
necessarily designed for people like me
to try to analyze it but um there's only
a few colleges and universities on the
vendor list and they all appear to be
accredited with the possible exception
of something called Ontario universities
but they got one grant for
$193 so they're not really a major part
of the program um and also section three
takes out special legal protections
granted to EFA recipients and to the
scholarship organization itself and
that's uh being the Judiciary Committee
um that uh that part of it doesn't
necessarily sit that well with me but um
so and hence hence Force if you use this
program to violate the law or violate
anyone else's Constitution or common law
rights you could be held liable just
like anyone else who misuses the
taxpayer's money or guess AB or so
that's um that's what those two things
are about and those might espe those two
things might stand without the uh rest
of the bill in
case case as you uh case as you work on
it you change in case you feel Maybe
maybe those parts of it have some Merit
you can consider those separately um so
it would forbid using the money for
Religious
Education um and I believe this art
program violates several articles of the
State Constitution especially part 1
article 6 and I guess I don't need to
read the whole thing it's in the written
testimony
um we'll parenthetically know the Carson
case came up in which is a US Supreme
Court about Maine I
um I didn't mention the first amendment
of my test precise because that case was
recently decided I think that was
specific to a main law which I think is
different from both what's being dealt
with in this bill and the subject matter
of the previous bill so we don't
necessarily know the Supreme Court if it
was asked to Pine on it would overturn
this if this became law um so we I think
it's worth I don't think that in itself
is an argument for killing the bill but
um and it doesn't merely allow St anyway
the program which is embodied in RSA
194f um doesn't merely allow taxpayer
funds to be used support religious
education it actively encourages that
and actually the same could be used
about the education tax credit program
um which actually this bill doesn't
address at all um that one's a little
bit different it doesn't take money
directly from the general education fund
so it's limited to the amount
voluntarily paid into it by the
participating taxpayers and um those are
I guess uh see sff enough differences I
decided not to attack that not to like
do anything about that program in this
bill both those two programs are
currently administered to a nonprofit
corporation called the children's
scholarship fund New Hampshire which
actually is ironically Incorporated in
New York City does have an office in
conquered
um but uh it's uh Incorporated in New
York City and they did actually the
parent organization did actually set up
a separate um cour entity just to
administer um the activities in New
Hampshire so even though it's part of a
larger
organization located in New York City
that uh is active in several other
states
um and I was a little bit suspicious I
want to first arrived here because it's
a very small organization um
administering a pretty complicated
entitlement program and basically on a
Cost Plus basis they seem to be just
getting a guaranteed percentage of
what's spent through the program um and
they hav't really been any scandals yet
there been scandals with similar prros
to other states but this one hasn't
really been a problem but I'm dubious of
it um you know especially with
the um especially the larger much more
ambitious School voucher program has
been added on top of that old tax credit
and U it's growing um almost out of
control I think so
it the CFS NH and the program it's
serves some home schools and secular
private schools but its main mission is
support religious education and they
really don't make any bones about you
look in their website you know they've
got the banner on the front page there a
bunch of adorable little children
apparently parochial school uniforms
with those bright yellow scarves that we
see on session days all the time will
undoubtedly see it on the day that this
bill comes to the floor um so they're um
you know they're very upfront about what
they're doing um what what their purpose
is and their conquered office is
actually literally located on the
property of the Catholic Church on
Lowden Road although we'll say it's
appears to be just looking from the
outside a pretty small office in a
church basement so I guess maybe they're
not wasting a lot of the taxpayers money
but um so as I said I think this is just
a blatant violation of the State
Constitution you know and the name
there's a whole bunch of it's also a bad
policy one of the big reasons um is he
gives the power to reward some religions
which is thees of while punishing those
it disapproves of cuz you know there's
uh this organization I I don't know if
they've denied any would be religious
Educators but U they certainly have they
certainly have the power to do so and
there's not much accountability or
there's no um you know they're not even
subject to uh 91a the right to no law so
it's hard and um so I was in the
legislature in 2012 when the ETC the
educ tax program was created and then of
course in 20 also 2021 when it was the
program we're talking about to they it
was created as part of the budget
trailer Bill and um I believe they put
the scholarship organization into that
program as administrator precisely with
the expectation they would be exempt
from many of the state and federal
regulations which is agency like the
State Department of Education would have
to obey so
I'm maybe that shouldn't be uh trying
top people's motives are but that
absolutely is of course the effect of
the bill as it was passed and there's I
was not the legislation 1995 with the
charged school public charged public
school programs established
but the laws governing that program
they've changed very little over the
past three decades um there is a bill to
tweak that program a little bit uh Miss
represent Horan can you stick to this
bill please not talking charter schools
here yes I'm just saying um that program
religious schools were Exempted from
that program almost 30 years ago and
um so okay I guess I can't put in a good
word for the bill about that which is
coming up here so the program recent
growth it's been pretty spectacular
almost entirely out of control um in my
opinion this would reduce the C amounted
by a significant amount certainly more
than half as I said the relevant data is
a couple years
old presented for format it makes it
hard to eventually analyze and um I
didn't have I made a little bit of
effort to see what else DOA can provide
me they referred me to CSF and I just uh
decided to stick with what was on the
website so I did a very crude analysis
of report called nhed by vendor spending
released in January 2023 which covers
expenditures apparently from November
2021 to June 202nd which shows that at
least 54% of the EFA dollars are being
spent paid directly to religious
institutions and I think that's actually
an understatement since um only about a
third of the program appears to be uh
most most a lot of the program is not
being spent directly on on tuition and
the uh tuition grants is shown in that
report and another one are usually less
than the full amount of the uh grants
that the families are receiving and it's
obviously less than the uh Less in the
cost of to these organizations um and I
have a list I have a list here of I
listed uh the I flagged all the schools
that appear to be religious judging by
their names or what I could glean about
them the you had to go down to about
number 10 on the list before you got a
non-religious school which is a school
called the high mowing School in Wilton
and that's
um and actually actually has a secular
that does have sort of a spiritual
Viewpoint it's clearly a secular school
and then
um a few others but the the all the
largest users of it are either parochial
schools or Christian Christian academies
organizations which are very
specifically religious schools which um
it's not necessarily a bad thing I don't
really know if that's either
constitutional or appropriate to use the
Hampshire taxpayer to directly support
those organizations but so that's um I
actually think this bill will probably C
of a lot more than 54% of the program
probably at least 75% or so because
um you know it would still leave secular
schools would still be so family senors
students of secular private schools like
the H mowing School the Philips heor
Academy has a few students in there and
a few others then also homeschoolers but
not the religious schools so that's um
that's my bill it's kind of simple in
principle and
um in case anybody ask me about the
Supreme Court decision that applies to
the main law which I think is different
than what we're considering here so I I
think I think this might pass thank you
are there any questions for represent
represent cordelli yeah um thank you
thank you representative Horgan for
being here again and and yes we did
recognize the name yes um the um the
subject um you brought it up and was
brought back brought up in context of
the earlier Bill also was the uh Carson
versus Mak decision but there are
Supreme Court decisions going back um as
that I know of as far as back as 1925
Pierce Versus Society of
sisters um all and you you can you don't
have to write all this down it's all on
my website repeal New Hampshire bla.com
yes I'll put in a plug um I know I know
Senator Blain he's been dead for a long
time but I know who he is yeah Blaine of
Maine yeah um in the 1990s there was
zelman versus Simmons Harris then
Trinity Lutheran versus comr yeah which
was all about trying to give um rubber
uh materials for school playgrounds to a
religious school that was um argued um
as being uh
unconstitutional um
then there more recently the past um
four years there was Espinosa versus
Montana Department of
Revenue um and then Carson versus Min
all of them held that if um funds are
going to a private school it would be
discrimination to exclude religious
schools um it would it I can give you
the quotes from Supreme Court justic
Roberts about it's being
neutral um to uh respect from for
religion um when this happens it's not a
violation of The Establishment Clause um
so I'm just wondering
how how you um you've mentioned that um
uh section three um on lines 5 through 7
um complies with our state constitution
I'm just wondering how you um get around
decisions I mean I guess I'll just say
my reading of it is blatantly violates
what's in our state constitution and we
um and as for the rest of those probably
before you execu you may want to have a
work session and review you know have a
have a discussion of those of those
decisions I I'm familiar with some of
them not familiar with others and um so
that's probably about the best answer I
have I just don't believe from what are
there any other question seen that those
invalidate my my law represent cordelli
thank you um I just wanted to bring up
you also touched in your testimony and I
believe you mentioned uh part one
article six of the
Constitution um uh the compelled reason
Clause it's commonly referred to and I'm
just wondering if if you're aware of the
history of that why it was added to the
Constitution um it was because back in
the
1700s towns were collecting Char uh
collecting money for the
churches um predominantly the
congregational churches and um in 1784
this was added to the Constitution so
you couldn't compel someone to pay money
to the Congregational Church but in
1791 there was a law passed that that
allowed towns to do this that was
eventually repealed in
1819 as other faiths started objecting
to uh collecting money for the
congregational churches they you know
they felt the you know they should have
uh equal uh equal dibs on that taxpayer
dollars I guess but um so that's the
history of article
one part one article six so I'm not sure
how that
um applies to um your attempt in uh
Roman 3 to exclude monies from um
religious
schools I I mean I might respectfully
disagree with the with the history um I
only been the legislation in 2008 so a
lot of those events happened uh before
my service um I guarantee you I wasn't
around in uh
184 I mean I I um there was the
separation of church and state you know
didn't really exist in the uh 1700s and
they kind of that evolved you know in
the middle of the 19th century and to
some extent I think it's because the uh
the churches didn't want to be uh part
of the state as much as the state uh
wanted to be separate from the churches
so a little of both and so there was a
move away move away from directly
subsidizing religious schools so they
still existed with private funding and
they do get a lot of uh tax advantages
so that's uh that's from my answer once
again you have an executive session
coming up you probably could if you
wanted to although have many bills have
a work session to like more examine
those Court decisions in more detail are
there any other questions for repres H
and represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair I am going to cut to the chase if
a law-abiding family is paying their
taxes and part of those taxes goes
towards funding public education and the
EFA program is designed to reimburse
some of that tax money back to the
family then why shouldn't they be able
to put their tax dollars towards a
religious school or whatever else they
all once again you have an executive
session coming up so you can discuss
that amongst yourselves I I believe the
tax mayor money belongs to all the
taxpayers not just you know so and in
some cases some of these families are
not necessarily in fact especially if
they're U within the original purview of
the EFA program they uh they wouldn't be
necessarily paying enough taxes to the
state to um you know offset what what's
being what's being paid as the grants
from the EFA program so and then also
course the EA program just the way it's
designed is a little bit my opinion kind
of kind of strange and open to abuse but
yes so I would I don't have a good
answer better answer than that but you
can discuss that amongst yourselves at
the exact questions from the committee
representative Luna thank you very much
um are
you being I mean being the being the
prime sponsor of this bill are you aware
that back in February actually February
15 2022 there was a letter from the
commissioner of Education to the Joint
um legislative committee on
administrative rules that um on
page I guess nine of the letter um uh
gets into and this is again from the
commissioner of educa New Hampshire educ
Department of Education to JL car that
the statute rules pertaining to um efas
instruction I'm sure you're I'm sure
you're correct I I remember uh following
some of that process so that particular
that particular letter I don't know
exactly what it says in page nine but
I'm sure I'm sure you're corre I'm sure
you're quoting him correctly so that
okay are you
followup yep followup thank you is are
are you under the impression that um
that
there that at least that direcor from
the commissioner to JL car is not being
followed by some uh EF some taxpayer
funded Education Service I would say so
yes yes okay thank you further questions
thank you very much represent Horgan I'd
suton
hey good morning for the record my name
is Matt suton um director of policy and
compliance at Children's scholarship
fund uh so we have a few questions on
this bill we would oppose this bill
because frankly it strips out the
protections for providers and we believe
that if we were put in that position we
would have to discriminate against
providers and as I just said the law
explicitly has protections for those
providers currently um I know that you
have tried to unpack Espinosa and Carson
and we believe that the state or we
believe that the US Supreme Court has
made it clear if you have a private
school choice program you can't
discriminate against uh religious
institutions so that's all I have thank
you very much other questions for Mr
Southern yes represent lus are you aware
of any monies actually going to
religious
training I do not that was an
interesting question that I heard would
that be I mean I would just be
speculating is that like Bible study is
that what they're talking about because
alls alls that we would pay for would be
tuition to a to a non-public school and
again we can't make those value
judgments we can't say you know as long
as you're approved by the bo Board of
Education you're approved by the entity
in your state to operate and we vetted
you we can't make moral or or or value
judgments on well we're going to we're
going to allow this one and we're not
going to allow that one it specifically
says in the law that we can't do that so
and this would strip that out so that's
what concerns us thank you represent
Cordell did you have your hand pass any
further representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair and thank you so much for
being here I had something I wanted to
clarify the previous representative said
that the current law as is may allow the
scholarship organization to choose to
fund one religious school as opposed to
another type of religious school may not
be funded but I just want to clarify
that's not the case and you can't
discriminate based on religion yeah no
that's that's absolutely not the case
okay thank you very much law F questions
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair it
it was noted obviously the the case Mak
was was implicated in this and uh but it
was suggested that that is not a reason
to kill this bill but if I were to look
at our house rules under 45 section D no
committee shall Report with a positive
recommendation any bill or resolution
which would if enacted be a violation of
any article of the Constitution of New
Hampshire or the Constitution of the
United States do you believe that this
bill if enacted would be
unconstitutional well I mean I'm not a
constitutional scholar but that's that's
what we're afraid of yeah that we'd be
breaking the law and that we'd be
discriminating against certain
individuals
representative
Boni thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I just wondering
if you could speak a little bit to your
vetting process because um we don't
really have access to that so I'm just
curious how you decide and we're
absolutely happy to share that process
with you it's a series of questions that
the um that one of our staff has to go
through you would you would you would
receive the application and you would
make sure it's a legitimate entity a
legitimate person say if it's it's a
little bit different if you're a sole
proprietor right and you're not a you're
not an organization how would we vet to
make sure that you have the credentials
and the experience to be able to teach
that job right so we would ask for your
resume we'd want ask for your work
experience we'd ask for any other
relative relative documentation and then
of course we have another we
would it's a little uncomfortable to say
this but we we we use the national insta
check for you know sexual predators so
we we do all that because you know what
we want to do is we want to make sure
that these are safe providers that these
that these students go to and ultimately
it's the parents decision to represent
Choice uh just a quick followup thank
you um so is it a committee that does
the vetting process is a a small I mean
is it one person it's it's typically
myself and then another member of the
compliance team and I'm absolutely happy
to email you that the instructions on
how we
proceed Prof ananana thank you is that
information um publicly available um not
just the questions but actually the
process well the process but also the
schools that you vet um is that
information publicly available their
their responses it's interesting so as
part of that as part of that um RFP that
we submitted last year we we we are
implementing a new process
that every um provider will need to um
when they when they register for for the
program and if we approve them then they
will have to lay out a number of those
documents there including how do they
provide a safe learning environment for
their student and and will those
documents be publicly available
absolutely they will be publicly
available and is this are you talking as
long as there I mean as long as we're
not talking about you know personal
sorry I'm sorry um as are you
representing the educational Freedom
accounts or the children's scholarship
children's scholarship fund so you're
just talking about that not the
absolutely and you can look at our new
policies and procedures we just updated
those a few weeks ago um that's online a
lot of that is I mean pretty much
everything should be public and if there
is information that you want or require
please let us know because we'll be
putting together an annual report at the
at the end of each year as a look back
um so that you'll be able to see all
these cost categories where the money
was spent uh the different vendors and
and all of those further
questions
represo thank you very much Mr chair has
the uh children's scholarship fund um
approved any expenses uh under the EFA
program for religious instruction not
that I'm aware of materials or services
used for religious
instruction I think are you talking
about I mean I I literally have to ask
you are you talking about a Bible or
what what could you define that for yeah
so so in the in the commissioner's um
own words in a letter to the uh to J car
uh set forth above the department
believes that as enacted the EFA law
does not permit the use of EFA funds for
religious instruction correct so that's
a that's an absolute statement yeah
that's my understanding so so I I just
want to be clear that the children's
scholarship fund has not approved any
EFA um any expenses under the EFA
program
for Educational Services or materials
that are being used for religious
instruction not to my knowledge but
again that's such a subjective question
I would need you to Define it so for
example is um is a
religious history textbook would that
be an item that you're describing so for
example we would consider that history
right we again we don't make value
judgments on how they want to teach
their students because they these are
these are approved non-public schools by
the state so so this this really gets
followup gets to religious instruction
and I'm just using the
commissioner's words here in this letter
back in February of 2022 to JL car and
and I I guess I'm just interested to
know whether or not the um children's
scholarship fund has approved the use of
EFA funds for any Educational Services I
believe is what it's called in
194f um Educational Services and
materials are part of Educational
Services um to be used for religious
instruction because the commissioner
here says that the rules and the Law
194f Bar the use of EFA funds for
religious
instruction so to my knowledge no and
again I would I would need to go back
and I need to check yeah and I would
absolutely definitely love to read the
material that you're reading and then
read um you know do we have a definition
on what those materials are thank you
very much thank you uh not see any
further questions I'd like to invite
Aubrey
Freeman uh Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman I live in Bridgewater
private citizen I speak in opposition to
this bill um so one of my points I was
going to make we already talked about
the uh Supreme Court US Supreme Court
already ruled an Espinosa versus the uh
Montana Department of Revenue so that
was June 2020 so that's pretty clear you
have to be neutral on religious schools
and school voucher programs so that's
all so to me this would just be a waste
of time this whole bill but my more
important points are actually this would
remove
government schools just don't work out
for everybody so that's what school
choice is all about If you eliminate
like 75% of the options what are those
parents going to do so this is removing
choices we want more choices not less
choices so that's the problem right here
secondly um I'm Jewish and when my son
he went to a regular government school
back in California K through 5 then I
decided no I don't think this is going
to the best option moving forward after
Elementary School I sent him to a
Catholic school and I have absolutely no
interest in Catholicism I had to go to
services and they were swinging that
weird smoke around and I know nothing
about that but I didn't care about any
of that the school had really high
standards the a went down to like 94% 93
was already in the E I said wo these
people have high standards academic
standards that's what I'm interested in
so the religious part people choose
religious schools for all different
reasons and um certainly for me I had no
interest in that but so he did you know
there was one class on religion it
didn't hurt him to learn it but it was a
good school and I think removing that
option is going to be devastating for
lot of parents who frankly I go to
school board meetings I know what goes
on in the schools they're not that good
people need other options and this
removes it so um uh even though I think
it be thrown out of court and every you
know just won't work but um it's a bad
idea and that's why I oppos this Bill
thank you very much are you willing to
take any questions yes yes questions
from the committee not see any thank you
very much and the last card I have here
is Jay Cole cook cook okay
okay wor when they mix up those last
letters
well looks like a different type of
writing I'm not good at that either
welcome this is amazing it's my first
time in front of anything like this and
I I can't believe I'm here I'm age 60 I
grew up in New Hampshire I did win a Dar
uh essay once uh why I love America when
I was like in fifth grade think it was
$10 Prize or something but this is the
closest I've gotten since then I've
spent about 30 years over uh Seas with
the military uh when I came back I
started a family late cuz uh during the
the wars we were extremely busy we
weren't you know making families so uh I
have young kids uh when I got back I
moved into what was considered to be one
of the nicer I mean you know it was an
apartment in a you know a multif family
unit but it was still in a neighborhood
that I presume was assigned to a good
Public School my mother is a had taught
at that school my sister is a public
school teacher in New Hampshire now my
cousin I have many friends who are
public school teachers uh I know for a
fact that there's some excellent lots of
excellent public schools in the
Hampshire and uh it's a terrible
thing when you're a father and you're
assigned to a
totally failed public school like Mount
Pleasant in nashwa and that's not the
only one in
nashwa it's a terrible thing uh
to to think because you don't have money
and like a lot of immigrants my wife is
an immigrant um because you don't have
the money to send your kids to a private
school that you have to consign them to
a failed public school and I'm not
talking about failed like you know I
don't like the look of it or uh you know
I don't like the feel it I'm talking
about go to the doe website and check
the measurements which a lot of people
don't do and it's starting to look like
almost
like like the legislature that people
don't like the idea of school choice at
all are uh are just throwing eggs just
throwing stones just anything they're
just trying to make something stick to
to end these
programs um like Mr I think fre Freedman
sir is it said uh you know my kids are
not Catholic my wife is not Catholic um
the school um I volunteer in it two
mornings a week before I go to my own
um stuff and I just uh I it's it's more
diverse than some Public Schools
especially in all in a very heavily
white New Hampshire there's tons of
Indians there's atheist Chinese in there
there there are Orthodox Jews Muslim
family um it's uh and so whatever
discussion is about religion there there
is a class they do teach a religion
class I don't want to be taking a knock
or helping the people are trying to kill
these programs but uh it's nothing it's
it's a it's a very short thing a week
and they also talk about Buddhism they
also talk about so any University today
I'm in you know I've taken a theology
class at Rivier they they you know they
some of them just focus on Christianity
some of them broaden out and at the
Catholic school you can do that
uh
it's it's it's enraging and I don't want
to be negative but it's enraging to
think that uh that somebody would try to
force us back into failed schools with
our children you only get one shot this
isn't like you're telling me that uh
you're not going to allow a supermarket
in my neighborhood I have to go to the
one I don't like cuz we can't get a new
one you're you're telling me that I have
to send my kids uh to uh to a bad school
and uh it seems like that this is like a
trojan horse for for teachers unions uh
support and not really an interest in in
uh the welfare and education of the kids
in New Hampshire I think Mr fredman
brought did it I don't have to repeat it
you know my kids are not Catholic um but
uh they've excelled um I know parents um
at that school who have in some cases
seven or eight kids and some of them
half them go to public school and half
go to the to the Catholic school and uh
unfortunately where we live and where we
are in
nsha uh and that won't maybe happen in
Hollis maybe not in Amis maybe not up
north maybe you guys got really really
good Public Schools you know my sister's
a good in a good public school this is
not about public school teachers I'm
supportive of public schools 100% so is
my wife she was against saying the kids
cuz she's not Catholic um but uh when
you're in a you're assigned to a bad a
really a failed public school that's
getting single digits on a scale of a
100 of proficiency which several uh
National schools are I know Manchester
does too I just follow some of the
stats you're not going to do that to
your children you're just not going to
do it and uh I just it it upsets me I
understand that maybe some people just
they hate the idea of of taxpayer money
uh being given back the taxpayers uh for
for private schools but it just seems
like at this point it's not even really
about that it just seems like for some
people it's just about trying to destroy
school choice and um them's fighting
words for me right now I got kids and I
spent did my time overseas I sacrificed
for 30 years over there it's enraging to
see people trying to just to destroy it
just because you know thank you I'm
sorry for no thank you very much for
coming today are there questions from
the committee excuse me no I don't see
any thanks lot thank you sir yep with
that we have no more cards on this
particular bill so we're going to close
uh
C Mr cook we're we're trying to get your
name written down correctly c k or c O
Okay itos that second o into a c that's
what they did when they got when I got
the Army the first time I just wanted to
go home so I left
lat well thank you for serving in the
Army thank you
sir there's a number of us in the Army
up here at this table absolutely
absolutely okay so we closed that
hearing on 1592 the next bill which we
ready he that should I should I start my
second please okay 1084 is a bill
relative to qualifications for the
commissioner of Education I'd like to
recognize represent selig thank you very
much um chairman lad and education
committee for allowing me to introduce
HB 1084 today for the record I am Lauren
selig I represent straford County
District 10 which is Durham in terms of
my background I'm a former teacher
certified in elementary education in
college having begun my career in
private kindergartens in New Jersey
then getting my masters in the art of
teaching with the focus on secondary
education specifically with English um
and English certification from the Johns
Hopkins University in Baltimore Maryland
I then taught middle and high school
English for a decade in Howard County
Maryland before I relocated to New
Hampshire um when I first moved here I
worked at the University of New
Hampshire supervising graduate students
who were getting their degrees to be
teachers and I held that position for 3
years until there was a 50% budget cut
for UNH and my position was one of many
that was
eliminated um I'm also the parent of two
Public School educated children and I am
a product of a blend of public and
private education having attended
private school for kindergarten and
first grade then Public School through
10th grade and back to private for my
last two
years this bill HB 1084 seeks to
reestablish minimum qualifications for
the commissioner of education and they
truly are minimum standards a degree
from an accredited college or university
certification as an educator and 5 years
experience as either a teacher or
administrator in a public school
system while I'm having trouble locating
the document um in the 1980s there was a
set of standards for all of our
commissioners including Commissioner of
Education um but they were removed in a
deregulation sweep during the Reagan Era
and have not been Revisited since this
bill seeks to create a bare minimum of
Standards Less in fact than most school
systems would require to hire someone as
a principal let alone a
superintendent yet the commissioner is
of education is fundamentally the
superintendent of all public school
systems in New
Hampshire um one document that I'm going
to share and I only printed one copy
because it's 40 something pages and I'll
hand that to your committee um gives
details of the requirements in States
across the country for this crucial
position but I pulled out a few key
highlights in Alabama the superintendent
of Education she'll be a person of good
moral character with academic and
professional education equivalent to the
graduation from standard college or
university who's knowledgeable in school
administration and has a training and
experience sufficient to qualify him I
would add or her to perform the duties
of office in Alaska the commissioner
shall have um at least a master's degree
with five years experience in the field
of education and at least three of the
five years in an exclusively
administrative position
in Arkansas the commissioner should have
a master's degree from an accredited
institution 10 years experience as a
teacher five of which have to be in an
administrative or supervisory nature in
Indiana they need to demonstrate
personal and professional leadership
preferably in administration of public
education they need an earned Advanced
degree preferably in education or
educational Administration awarded from
a regionally or nationally accredited
college or
university they also have to have a
license or have held a license as a
teacher superintendent or principal or
any combination of these for at least 5
years prior to taking the office and at
least 5 years work experience in any
combination of teacher superintendent
principal or executive in the field of
Education as I said I've got 41 pages I
could go on but I I don't think that's
necessary additionally I spoke to a
number of people who do hiring for towns
for small businesses and for large
corporations to see what they look for
when hiring or appointing someone to a
senior supervisory position
unequivocally they stated expertise in
the field preferably a directly related
Advanced degree in the area being
supervised a progression of jobs in the
industry showing they are prepared and
have the core skills and experience to
fully understand all aspects of the
organization they are supervising as
well as a demonstrated interest in
supporting that
organization in case all of this is
difficult to understand in theoretical
mode here's an example that might be
more clear imagine you have a badly
broken leg with multiple fractures and
Bone protruding from your
skin you wouldn't want me to be your
surgeon even though I've spent hours
binge watching ER Grace's anatomy and
mash I mean I did pass biology in high
school and topics in contemporary
chemistry in college and I attended the
emergency incident training at lunch
here in the state house last spring but
none of that makes me qualified to
perform the procedure nor to supervise
the Doctor Who
should I began my testimony by saying
I'd attended both public and private
school when I was younger and that I
taught both public and private school
it's one reason why this bill specifies
experience working in a public school
system by law and also by good moral
standards Public Schools cannot
discriminate about who attends them they
cannot block a child who might be slower
to develop or is learning disabilities
or even those with severe behavioral
challenges from attending believe me I
know I taught those
kids there are requirements to provide
all sorts of services from public
schools and report to any student and
Reporting requirements for any student
who wants to enroll so the person who
heads up the organization that is
supposed to ensure that all of our kids
are getting a quality education should
be familiar with how public schools
actually work what some of the Dynamics
and challenges are and what makes them a
truly unique and wonderful example of
how to create a more perfect
union the success and strength of public
school should be reflected in its
leaders there currently isn't that
visibility in supporting teaching and
learning in the public school setting
nor is there an understanding empathy
and support for the difficult scenarios
and situations School administrators and
teachers face every day um that must
face every day to keep our kids safe fed
and educated um I hope you will support
this bill and will demonstrate a
commitment to meeting the needs of
students across New Hampshire
additionally um I'm going to be passing
out uh written testimony from uh
representative Nick dmana who's also a
professor at Keen um ke
State ke anyway Keen um he's teaching
this morning but I have his written
testimony and I want to highlight from
your online testimony the New Hampshire
Association of school principal
submitted their written testimony um in
support of this bill focusing on the
fact that the role requires a deep
understanding of the complexities of the
education system as well as the ability
to navigate the everchanging landscape
of educational legislation and funding
um they go on later to say that the role
of Commissioner of education at the
state level in the United States is a
highly demanding position that requires
a combination of educational expertise
leadership experience and effective
communication skills they have much more
in their letter I'm just highlighting a
couple parts and in the online testimony
submissions there are currently 209
people who've submitted in support 20
who opposed and just one that's
neutral thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
represent
leus you were talking about the broken
leg and I'm wondering
if you had a choice between a doctor who
had worked at a private institution that
specializes in broken legs or a general
doctor who worked at a public
institution but that you know that
institution is not done well um which
would you want to go to I'd want the
Doctor Who was qualified to do the
surgery and so does where they got their
experience
matter I I would say that what makes
someone qualified definitely has to do
with their experience yes and I don't
believe that someone who has never had
any experience working in a public
school system truly understands the
Dynamics of how they work thank you uh
repr sen cascaden and representative
cordelli thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question I
don't know if you have um explored the
RSA 21 um in preparing this but I just
want to point out a couple things and
then get your response to that so an RSA
21 N3 is about the commissioner and
Deputy uh commissioner uh positions and
one of the criteria is the commissioner
and Deputy
Commissioner um shall be qualified to
hold their positions by reason of
education and
experience and RSA 21
and-4 the duties of a commissioner
specify that they are are to be
representing the public interest in the
administration of the function of the
Department of Ed and does this bill
change anything in that RSA in
particular or are we just not following
this RSA my belief is this would
strengthen that RSA by making it more
specific that they would also have to
have experience within a public school
system so that they understand the
Dynamics of public schools thank you
represent Celli uh thank you just going
back to uh 21 and4 the duties of
commissioner
um I'm having trouble finding anything
in there in terms of the duties of a
commissioner that would require them to
have been a certified teacher or
administrator could you point me to any
of the duties that
would representative cascaden just
referen
them
I General experience and responsibility
requires you to have been a certified
I I don't have further further questions
from the committee represent belshire
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you you suggested
that the these particular um
qualifications are comparable to what is
required for a school principal no I
said that they were less than what would
be required for a school principle but
they I was as the bill States these
would be absolute minimum standards not
maximum ideally it would be someone with
an advanced degree with many years
experience I know my school district
recently hired a new superintendent and
they chose to take hire the person with
20 years of experience versus the person
who had thank you for that correction if
I may continue my question um if this is
the minimum set of or less than the
minimum that is generally required for
uh principles yet we know that all over
the state we have schools that are
struggling including some that are
outright fake failing then these do not
obviously confer some sort of magical
ability to a principal to manage a
school why would this result in in a
good uh
commissioner uh I'm not saying that this
would be the maximum standards very
specifically it it's the minimum
standards that we would want someone
with at the very least a basic
understanding of how Public Schools work
someone who has worked within a public
school system and seen the varying
Dynamics and the changes that happen
within a public school system which are
unique to public schools and are not and
don't occur in private schools in
charter schools in um homeschooling
environments or for people who have no
experience at all in education um the
Dynamics of a business for example like
the person who runs my Supermarket um
they're outstanding at identifying the
needs of the
supermarket but I wouldn't want them to
do my leg surgery and I also don't
believe they're qualified to run my
school they are very good at the product
they provide um just as a factory owner
would ideally know the best way to to
run their Factory our schools are not
factories our schools are sources of
education and support for all
students F the questions if I may just
thank you because that helped clarify
what what we're looking at I think in
terms of this so if I'm if I understand
correctly the the point of implementing
these minimum standards is because that
would allow for a person who's filling
this position to understand how the
current system operates such that they
can continue to reproduce the current
system no it might allow them to make
amazing changes to the system maybe what
they recognize is the way in which the
system doesn't work right now and needs
to be improved or maybe they recognize
that this school district is doing
things well and this one isn't and that
there's ways of partnering those school
districts to improve both thank you
represent Woodcock thank you chairman L
um good morning again good morning I'm
looking at uh just something very misu
really but on line 12 of your proposed
bill
and I'm not suggesting I have anything
against your upper your upper
suggestions on 8 n tanks I agree with
those um however on line 12 if this bill
became effective July 1
2024 what would happen to the current
incumbent of that position U who has
three years left on their contract so I
asked OLS if we could have it state that
date or at the conclusion of the current
commissioner's term and they said we had
to pick a specific date so I I don't
actually have the answer to your
question um I just know that ol said we
couldn't make it in or as a an effective
date and we had to pick a day okay thank
you thank you CH L further questions
represent
cascaden thank you Mr chair and just uh
followup to give a little bit more
clarity so again RSA 21 does specify
qualified to hold their positions by
reason of education and experience to me
that's not just any experience it's
particular to the
field but would your town hire a fire
chief and a police chief who has not
been a firefighter or a police officer
just curious uh I mean I can't speak to
other people's towns I only know the way
my town works and absolutely not they
would never hire someone who wasn't
qualified to do the job represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair am I correct
in saying that this bill would put more
qualifications into statute for the
commissioner of Education than compared
to commissioners of other departments
say Transportation agricultural natural
and cultural resources to name a few are
do those Commissioners also have
comparable qualifications written out in
statute um so this bill specifically is
addressing this issue um in uh next year
we can bring forward legislation to make
sure that all of our commissioners
across boards are qualified in their
specific areas I I didn't um as a first
term legislator think it was appropriate
for me to submit 20 separate bills this
year I felt that I would focus on one at
a time and make sure that I was doing it
effectively may I have a followup yes
you may so you would see this bill as a
start of further
regulations for government officials is
this the start of more future bills no I
see this bill as one to make sure that
we have a commissioner of Education who
is actually qualified to be the
commissioner of Education
okay further questions thank you very
vote thank you Mr chairman good morning
good morning honorable members of House
Education committee it's been a hot
minute since I've been behind a
microphone so I appreciate you listening
to my testimony today um for the record
my name is Robin vote I a former State
Representative of Rockingham district 21
and I'm now a resident of the amazing
little town
of Durham New Hampshire um and I am
speaking today in favor of HB
1084 um I spent 10 years in New
Hampshire Public Schools as a PA
professional and four years as
co-president of the exitor PA
professionals Association so for over 10
years I've been working with uh special
needs students and uh kind of on the
front lines of uh that work um I'm
speaking today in favor of HB 1084
because when it comes to education and
providing enriching learning
opportunities in the state of New
Hampshire the individuals leading those
efforts in the New Hampshire Department
of Education should understand exactly
how the a classroom school or how a
district as a whole works in my 10 years
of experience as a par professional I've
held many responsibilities and was
required to consistently improve my
practices either through extending my
college degree or seeking additional
certifications to do the job of
educating
students this is what makes a good
Public School educator or administrator
a dedicated Community leader and an
educator as a whole here in the state of
New Hampshire the drive to become even
better at the work that we do to
accomplish This months of experience in
the classroom logging of hours with
students and careful review of practices
by an administrator or College advisor
are needed the qualifications needed to
become certified or in many cases to
even be considered for position of par
par professional classroom teacher or a
school administrator in New Hampshire
are important to ensuring that the best
of the best are educating our students
the fact that our Commissioner of
education and Deputy Commissioner of
Education State officials making crucial
decisions about educating New
Hampshire's next Generations may not
have experience in a classroom or have
not even been through the same processes
that so many Educators and
administrators are required to by New
Hampshire Department of Education
standards simply makes no sense to me if
I have years of experience in Business
Administration and accounting with no
experience educating New Hampshire stud
students in minimal to zero hours
towards a state certification in
teaching or even in the process of my
cags should that qualify me to lead the
charge for New Hampshire's education
system in any other job application the
hiring manager for the position would
look at that resume and say we're going
to pass they have no relevant experience
we hold the same standards for any other
job in this world currently that
relevant experience and specific
qualifications are necessary to be even
considered for the role it's about time
that commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner of Education are held to
that standard as well for the position
you must have experience working or
being an administrator in one of our
many Fantastic New Hampshire Public
Schools I ask you to please support HB
1084 and for the work of so many
administrators and Educators here in New
Hampshire thank you and I'm open to any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee not
seeing it thank you very much thank you
Freeman
M Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
fredman Bridgewater private citizen
again I'm going to oppose this bill and
similar to the last bill this bill is
all about eliminating flexibility and
options the thing is the government
schools if you hire people only that
come that worked and you know got to
have the 5 years more experience you're
getting people from the inside people
from the inside are not going to change
the system I'm not saying they're not
qualified and they just have it's a
world view of youve come from that
system it's good and it's got to stay a
certain way and and maybe we can tweak
it a little bit they're not going to
make major changes you need people from
the outside and that's why it doesn't
mean you can't have people from the
inside but having more options uh I
think is better for everyone and you get
a fresher view fresh blood um also B uh
schools are a business and a lot of
people say education is it's different
it's the kids Minds no it's not
different it's a business the business
should be teaching academic skills that
is a business and I'm sorry to say the
government schools are not doing a great
job they're trying to do too much right
now they're not focused let's get back
to it is a business business of
educating academics the basic stuff and
I think having the options of getting
people with experience and uh from the
outside running businesses that can
actually accomplish the goal at hand is
worthwhile to have that flexibility and
I think limiting limiting it to people
basically from the inside the system is
doomed to failure and that's why I
oppose this Bill thank you very much are
you willing to take questions yes
questions from the committee represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L good
morning thank you for coming back again
um if you wanted to uh create a new
system would you feel more comfortable
bringing someone who is focused on
creating new systems in a specific field
or someone who just creates new systems
well I don't think we can bring in a a
new system at this point so I'd say
improving okay that the question yeah
May the question to be clear if you were
creating a new system would you prefer
to have someone who has experience in
the system and recreating it or someone
who has no experience to recrea a
system I want all yeah I just want all
the options open I I don't want limiting
options thank you thank you further
questions now see thank you very much
thank you uh Jennifer
Belmont
thank you chairman Rick lad and
education committee my name is Jennifer
Belmont Earl I live in barington with my
husband and our two School AG children I
support HB 1084 because both of my
children are autistic and receive the
legal right to an appropriate education
in public
school currently our Commissioner of
education does not need to have any
background in public education this can
result in blind spots including the
right of children with disabilities to
access a free and appropriate public
education also known as fate as outlined
in the individuals with disabilities
Education Act idea every child is
entitled to fape someone with a
background in public education is more
likely to understand the complexity and
implementation of all of the pieces of
the current educational system in
place my fear is that my son Zeke who is
non-verbal and has sensory challenges
could somehow be pushed out of a public
school and lose
fape he is in an integrated preschool
program where Educators help him make
friends with both typical children and
children who experience disability he is
learning to recognize the letters in his
name and to spell along with his abled
classmates if he were to attend a
private school specifically for autistic
children there is no law guaranteeing
that he would receive the appropriate
education that his other typical
classmates would
receive he also definitely would not be
helped to make friends with neurotypical
children and and the friends he has now
would miss an opportunity to know my
wonderful
son the education of our children is
complex presenting many challenges that
only someone with a working knowledge of
our system could Navigate please pass HB
1084 because the state commissioner and
Deputy Commissioner of Education should
have some prior experience in public
education thank you thank you very much
other questions from the committee not
see thank you very
much repr luus I'm just curious as to
why you're afraid that your son will be
pushed out of the public school have you
been given any reason not of my public
school I have friends who um whose
autistic children when they they get
older they're more likely to be
um
politely asked to leave if you know what
I mean um
so I I feel that some people that send
their um disabled children to schools
specifically for kids with
disabilities um may not have um the
options that they should okay thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee represent luno thank you very
much um and and and thanks for for
coming today and providing your test on
this do you think it would be sufficient
in in in view of some of the other
comments we've we've we've heard this
morning that if we had a commissioner of
Education that actually had a background
in in education and in public schools um
that if we had a commissioner with that
sort of background that they would be
able to receive advice from their um
their state board of you know the State
Board of Ed education members who by law
um seven members Who Shall Serve without
pay we're all used to that shall not be
technical Educators or professionally
engaged in that work that they would
that the commissioner being a skilled
educator credential educator would be
able to receive advice from people who
were not professional Educators and that
that would serve the public interest in
terms of having working knowledge of the
of what go What what schools do and
other knowledge I I mean it could I am a
parent though so so this is not my area
of expertise okay thank you thank you
very much further questions thank you
very much thank you oh and if I may um I
have written testimony um from another
parent I'd like to submit hand it in
right over there and they'll pass it
around to
kadema
good morning good morning
everyone um thank you chairman Rick lad
and education committee my name is
Gloria Mandi I reside in Manchester New
Hampshire and I'm a single M of two boys
my oldest boy is 8 years old and on the
artist Spectrum I support HP 1084
because public education is complic get
it and require someone at the helm with
more than just a basic understanding of
how how it operates I graduated with a
bachelor degrees in business finance 13
years ago but I struggled advocating for
my son I initially trusted the education
system after two years in school my uh I
noticed that there had been no growth in
my my son functional Behavioral or
academic abilities he used to enjoy
singing from the age of 1 to three and
used to pronounce a few words but
instead of developing them at school he
regrets he lost his speech while
undergoing speech therapy and obtaining
all proper assistance even something as
easy as an AAC device a common support
for communication was denied to my son
in first grade I realized I had to start
taking matters into my own hands
particularly when I started receiving
calls to pick up my son from school
because he was having l ly Tantrums or
meltdowns behavior that are common when
children do not have access to
communication tools his teacher were
AOSS on how to handle it as an educated
woman I had to a knowledge I did not
know enough to fully advocate for my son
I delve more into learning about my
son's condition the educational system
and disability the more I learn the more
I recognize education is complicated
based and I became and I began my master
degree in special education when I
learned the commission of the New
Hampshire Department of Education was an
accounting professional without any
special education experience I was
perplexed to me it makes no sense for
someone lacking special education
training or any training in education to
make decision on behalf of New Hampshire
children families and Educators my
business degree will have served me well
if education were a business fortunately
it's not the commission of education has
a complicated job within a complicated
system special education is a Bas all on
its own it is of the utmost importance
to have an amendment in place requiring
a background in special education
instruction New Hampshire is growing and
becoming more diverse this holds
significant importance for my family
particularly those of us for whom
English is a second language navigating
a foreign culture and learning the
language is difficult enough knowing how
to advocate for a child with develop and
delay further complicated situation
thank you for your time thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee representative Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for being here I
think your son is a very fortunate child
to have you as his mom with the effort
that you have put into understanding
what his needs are and I'm wondering if
you would comment in your work to get I
believe you said your Masters in special
education do you think there's a
parallel between the increase in your
knowledge and understanding of how to
help and advocate for your son and what
a uh Commissioner of Education qualified
in the way this bill proposes to be in
the different knowledge level and
philosophies that might occur from that
difference yes um it made a lot of
difference um especially when I because
before when I was in those meeting I
didn't know how to defend or his right
or or any more knowledge when because
every time I would come to ask for a
request for something I was put on the
wall like it it could not happen but
since I've been furthering my knowledge
and taking the special education I did
understand a lot of stuff so he he
permit me to better advocate for him
during the meetings and and I see a
change since I I um I studed better uh
advocating he started receiving Services
because I had more knowledge and better
to defend the request that was coming
after further questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
today thank you I'd like to have
sers thank you Mr chair thank the
committee for hearing my testimony uh on
HB 1084 I look at it as my one of my
constituents Aubrey Freeman just
mentioned to you it's a business and as
any of us going into business we know a
lot about a business or we have a hot
for it but it doesn't mean we know all
aspects of it and what we do is we surpr
we actually surround ourselves with
experts that's what we do and that's
what the I think any commissioner would
do at this point or Deputy Commissioner
they would hire the right people around
them or as advisors to make sure they're
doing the best job they can so I look at
this is that opposing this bill gives
more freedom and allows more freedom uh
to the person that's going to be in that
position and again if you're saying that
someone has to have a college
education that doesn't make sense
because we just talked in previous bills
about uh social emotional learning that
is taking over and what's causing that
is uh Caple saying hey if they're more
socially and emotional they're going to
actually learn on their own by going out
to the internet and actually learn and
develop their skills on academics so if
they go out and do that they may not end
up going to college but they're going to
go on the internet and learn all they
can on a certain subject so therefore
you'll be you'll be um taking people
that might be qualified because there
are a lot of really smart people out
there that just haven't gone to college
and I just that one reason alone is I'm
saying you'd be discarding a bunch of
people that actually could be good for
the position and the position is not
just given anybody I'm sure they're
going through an interview as well so
again I'm opposing this bill un that's
the reasons why thank you very much are
there any
questions thank you thank you uh
Horgan um thank you I'm represent Tim
Timothy hor stford County District 10
the town of Durham so I U I support this
bill I thank the prime sponsor who's
also from my district for bringing
forward and uh for my neighbor former
represent voted for coming to speak in
behalf of it so I think this is a you
know fairly Common Sense Common Sense
bill
um and of course there's the uh and you
if
you I mean you are certainly free to
amend it too if you if you object
somebody the fact that the person's has
to have five years of experience in a
public school which of course is a
pretty minimal amount for a commissioner
of of any Department you know you can uh
get your Advanced degree and be
certified and um get five years combined
experience before you're 30 years old
and all the Commissioners are uh you
know much older than that not that
people under 30 aren't aren't very
skillful too so I think as a practical
matter uh I think that those are all
very reasonable requirements we've heard
it said that the Public School System
New Hampshire is failing um it's far
from perfect but the idea that it's
totally failing is uh I think uh I think
fallacious I can understand if you
choose to send your kids to private
school which is a very legitimate Choice
uh you may uh you may have sort of
you're emoly attached to whatever School
you send your kids to so far that may be
you know sort of a prival saying the
private schools are terrible but they're
um they're not perfect but most of them
are most of them are pretty good if you
go to a private school if you go to a
any public school here you'll see uh
very adorable kids doing very wonderful
things um just like you do when you go
to a charter school which is sort of a
hyper between a public and private
school or you know a private school and
also by the other same token not all the
private schools in Hampshire are perfect
like
um like I I know of someone who sent a
uh their some of their children to a
public school some of them to a private
school that was actually listen on the
EFA vend list um not near the top
farther farther down um she I think she
felt that the uh Public School actually
provided a better foundation for those
kids and the ones who Oran can you speak
to the bill please I'm specifically to
the changes in this bill oh I think it's
a I think it's a very reasonable thing
to expect a person to have experience in
the public school system that is the
major part of the Doe's uh Mission
although it does also oversee other
forms of education and um even if we
assume for the sake of argument that's
corrected the public school system is a
total failure you should at least want
somebody who uh who knows why it failed
which I and I don't agree that it's a
total failure and also I think um you
know the and people criticize the
incumbent the incumbent was a very smart
guy he he was asked to take the job and
he got it and I think he's doing the
best he can but he was not I think that
was not necessarily the best decision
that was uh that was made by the current
governor but um this isn't about him
it's about what goes on forward and also
I think somewhat I think somewhat if we
have somebody who's really just very
invested and somehow the idea of the
public school system has failed that's
not necessarily a good thing to have
them in charge it would be like say if
we had somebody's convince that our
highways are total failures that they're
falling down and in fact they're in good
condition I I drove up the entire link
to the Edward ever at Turnpike you know
so if we had somebody who like wanted to
privatize the turnpike system as their
cause we wouldn't want them necessarily
being charged of the do if in fact um as
as anybody drives our turnpik the
turnpikes are not falling down they're
in good condition and um I think the
same is true the the CH education should
be somebody who has at least a certain
amount of confident understands that
there's both good things and bad things
going on in the public schools so that's
uh I think it's a very I think it's a
very reasonable uh it's these are very
uh these are very low expectations for
the commissioner of Education I'm sure
any future Governor will have no problem
finding uh many people with all sorts of
different viewpoints who meet those
minimal requirements so I I urue to pass
the Bill are there any questions for
represent Horgan sure represent Bel
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question you you made a
comparison to the dot and we wouldn't
want a do commissioner who wanted to
privatize the roads but given given what
we're seeing in this bill are you
suggesting that the that part of the uh
rationale for doing this or that the
effect of doing this is to Institute a
permanent sort of political preference
among this job to continue a certain
policy um well no I was that wasn't my
point although I guess my point although
I guess I do believe that the policy
that the private public schools are a
total failure in the entire education
system should be privatized I think
that's uh that's simply not a correct
view and it's not practical to uh to
implement so that but but um that's I
may be making maybe exaggerating
somewhat even what the uh current
commissioner believes but certainly um I
think the idea
that the idea that we shouldn't have the
idea that certainly I think I think it's
reasonable to expect the Department of
Education to be headed by somebody who's
at least spent a few years uh teaching
in the public schools like um you know I
thank you thanks further questions from
the committee not see any thank you very
much and we will close this hearing
we'll start the next hearing at 12:30 in
this
room
well good morning afternoon to everybody
and welcome to the education committee
um obviously this bill has attracted a
lot of folks folks we have folks in this
room and three other rooms where it's
all being streamed so I hope everybody
can hear me throughout the four rooms
including this one uh 1610 is relative
to standardized assessment data for
participants in education Freedom
accounts and we'll start it off here in
a few moments but I want to lay out some
of the ground rules and how we're going
to function here
today um due to the nature the number of
people that request to speak we're going
to limit testimony to two minutes two
minutes per person and we will then
aside from the person that presents the
presenter as policy and the education
committee has the time needed to present
and discuss the bill with the committee
from that point forward including any
Representatives that come forward it's
only two minutes uh per person so we try
to be equal and fair to
everybody um if you have written test
testimony we ask that you not read it
for btim try to give us the high points
on that testimony so and because we will
getting get all the written copies that
are presented to us in fact what I'm
going to do is rather than you'll see us
passing paperwork around here that comes
in from people testifying we're going to
try and collect it at either end and we
chrisc cross it and then hand it out to
the committee following this Committee
hearing from all the days that I was
teacher principal administrator in
school
districts it's better that we give our
attention to the audience to the people
testifying rather than sit here and read
while somebody else is trying to testify
I I don't think that's polite it's
basically rude so what we will do is we
will stack all that information on
either end pass it out at the conclusion
of the committee to all the people in in
the room if something's already been
been said by another person
you can give your story yes but don't
try to rehash the same thing over and
over from the looks of it we have
overflow to account account for about
250 folks if you multiply even just 200
times 2 minutes per
person and divide it by 60 minutes per
hour you can see we're going to be here
for over six
hours so uh with that we we got to be
respectful of each other and try to move
on so with this I'd like to go right
ahead into the hearing today and welcome
representative cascaden who is the Prime
sponsor of the bill welcome thank you Mr
chair members of the committee for the
record Karine
cascaden um representing Coos District 5
city of
Berlin um and I'm here to present
testimony on House Bill
1610 um and I have to say uh I commend
all of those parents who choose whatever
choice of education program they want um
I have willingly taught in private
schools and in public schools as well so
teaching and learning is really my forte
and I have a 45y year career in it um I
feel bad a little bit because every time
something comes up with education
Freedom account there is a
defensive attitude that we are going to
impact parent choice and I want to be
clear that parents have always had
choice for education and they should
continue to always have choice I don't
think we should regulate A Parent's
Choice on how or where to educate their
kids so the attent of this bill is to
collaborate in a bipartisan way with
committee education Freedom account
Advocates who have proposed the need to
address proficiency levels in reading
and math abilities for all students
public information on student
proficiency level proficiency levels in
reading and in math is available
currently on the department of Ed
website in the link of data reports
under I aieve platform however students
who don't attend public schools do not
share academic proficiency levels this
bill is for incoming is for only
informing the New Hampshire Public of
proficiency levels in reading and math
of students who are recipients of
Education Freedom accounts this bill is
not intended in any way though it was
not clarified in the original Bill
language it is not intended to address
proficiency of any homeschool students
because they are not receiving public
funds generated by property
taxpayers RSA
194f currently requires EF recipients to
submit evidence of learning the EFA law
states that quote all students renewing
the EFA Grant must provide a record of
educational attainment close quote the
state distributes money from the
education trust fund to parents and
Guardians via a digital
wallet and the required assessment
standards or educational attainment
attainment are currently submitted to
the scholarship fund thus New Hampshire
taxpayers who fund parents to choose how
to educate have a right to know how
students are performing in reading and
math we know through the use of the efas
some learn how to drive some engage in
various sports program some learn music
and arts but we really don't know what
the academic proficiency levels are
standardized tests have a critical role
in
education and I don't
Advocate that every single
student is going to respond to a
standardized test and there are always
exceptions to the rule there has to be
we're talking about kids not things and
so they vary um while the national
assessment of Education progress which
is known as Nate
has been used in this committee before
is a reliable assessment it is based on
a representative sample of students and
schools must volunteer to participate
and a test is administered every two
years in grades 48 and 11 this
assessment cannot be used to measure
individual student growth or proficiency
over
time this bill 1610 does not change the
EFA requirements it is simply a
housekeeping bill that directs the
scholarship organization to submit
proficiency levels of students to the
Department of Ed to post in a public
data report platform like I
achieve I will have an amendment to add
Clarity and to not impact any provisions
in the law for hom school students House
Bill 610 will also satisfy one of the
requirements from the education freeding
savings account oversight committee who
recently submitted a report public
report dated November 30th
2023 um and the recommendation number
three was identify current and Future
tools or metrics for student performance
and accountability including how the
school and educational setting
demonstrate accountability so House Bill
1610 is in the best interest of students
it provides transparency to the public
and it provides accountability as
requested by the Legislative oversight
committee and I have um circulated leave
my extras on the table there just to
show you an
example um of what the department of Ed
has and I have had conversation with
Caitlyn Davis about this um they're when
when they report their um achievement
scores of all the schools in the state
there is a cover page that talks about
the number of students who have taken
the assessment and you all know that
there's an opt out um option and there
are also accommodations available but it
just identifies that there was a total
of
167,50 students in New Hampshire who
took the Statewide assessment and I'm
not sitting here to say every student
should take the Statewide assessment
because it's not the only measure um so
you can see the number of students
across the state when you look at the
backside is also a tab called
proficiency and growth and I wanted to
draw your attention to that because it's
growth over time
and that's what teaching and learning is
planned from and you can look at in the
most C current
data what the pre-pandemic and the
post-pandemic achievement is and
certainly if you look at Ela grades 3 to
8 and 11 you can see that prepandemic
pandemic achievement levels have not
been attained yet but if you look at the
achievement data from the covid period
of 2020
and 3 years beyond that you can see that
there is steady growth at all grade
levels um and it would seem to me that
it would be pretty easy to be able to
just add either a page or a category
that identifies x amount students
receiving efas at a certain grade level
or it maybe age level because we don't
know what kind of learning platform and
they may not all be following a
traditional grade level but it's to make
sure that we know our kids learning how
to read um and are they learning math
facts and what's important in math um so
that's that's what the bill is about and
it's it did not
initially bring that forth um the bill
really had identified a different RSA
but it really is specific to 194 which
is the education freedum account
sections and that's it Mr chair thank
you very much representative cascaden
are there any questions from the
committee yes representa leus
I noticed that you haven't changed the
part that says unless each student is
EXA all public school students in the
designated grade shall participate in
the assessment unless such student is
Exempted from taking the test by his or
her parent and currently the EFA
students have three ways of evaluating
students and this would be one of the
ways they would have right so by not
choosing this way but by choosing a
different way aren't they in
effect exempting them from this I
mean do you what do you want a piece of
paper from the parent that says I'm
exempting my kid and therefore I'm
choosing this method instead of that
method because that's all that would
happen I don't administer this program
sorry is there a copy of the
amendment you no um the Amendments have
have been held pardon me no no I don't
have an amendment at this time okay
representa
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um actually have
two but they're linked but I'll ask for
a followup in between um so let's say
that I mean obviously that the point is
the of administering these standardized
test I think is generally thought of as
as improving things over time but let's
say we have administer these uh home
these tests to homeschool students and
we find some deficiencies
what are you proposing that the state
does about that first of all I'm not
concerned about the progress of a
homeschool student I'm concerned about
the progress of students who are
dollars go ahead
followup so same question except
recipients of EFA funds that are
homeschooling their
children I'm not getting into the weeds
of who's homeschooling who's not I'm
very concerned about my tax
dollars and where they go and and the
it and if I if I may just one one follow
up on that uh
so regarding the very many government
run or public schools that have
demonstrated low test scores failing
level test scores in some cases on these
standardized tests we've heard many
times in this committee from many
members of this committee that the
schools are fine but the tests are not
properly measuring performance so are we
now assuming based on what we're seeing
in front of us that these tests are good
and they are properly measuring
performance I can only speak to the
public document on the department evet
website I don't know about other
standardized tests that are being used
because there's a number of them and
certainly to be able to upload say a
common measure nobody needs to know
whether somebody's taken one test or
another but to to upload a common
measure to a certain group there is anal
an uh analytic software that would
convert that to one measure whether it's
a percentile measure or any type of uh
range of proficiency
level just for clarification purposes uh
for everybody in the rooms we have
compulsory attendance laws in the state
and there's four categories within where
you can accomplish compulsory attendance
or meet it one is you're in a public
school two you're in a private school
three you're a homeschooler and fourth
the education Freedom accounts they are
separate items each one of them separate
systems for meeting compulsory
attendance in this state so that's for
clarification purposes thank you further
questions uh represent Kaden represent
cordelli um thank you um uh I just
wondering if you are aware um it's been
brought up several times about um um
efas um being used uh using public
dollars to purchase education options
but uh are you aware that Supreme Court
on a number of occasions including
zelman versus Simmon Harris had said
that once those public
dollars are put into an account for the
parent they are exercising private
choice they are no longer um using
public funds at that point are are you
aware of that
I don't I'm not aware of it no and I'm
looking out for what's best for
kids further
questions thank you very
much um no more further questions from
the committee for
you um the way we handle these committee
uh hearings is that we try to get the
representatives are wanting to testify
out of the room so they can get back to
a room where they're breaking away from
where they need to be working there and
so I do have three cards from
Representatives here I'm going to go
through those three Representatives then
what I will be doing is starting to call
as the stack comes up here the the folks
to testify from the general public and I
will call them up and they'll have a
name for somebody on deck and a little
bit of baseball for those that are in
the hole so that you have time to get
ready to come down the hallway if you're
not in this room uh to testify so I'd
like to call forward uh representative
now thank you Mr chairman and good
morning committee yeah and by the way
it's two minutes for everybody there for
there I'll be less than a minute I I saw
30 seconds so it's great all right ready
go for the record I represent the town
of marac Hillsboro 12 and I'm the House
Majority Whip I just wanted to go on
record to publicly um oppose this bill
I'm going to leave you with one quote
from the 1925 case Pierce versus the
Society of sisters the child is not the
mere creature of the state thank you
thank you very much any questions for
the
representative uh now this is another
point of order in this room there is no
clapping allowed in this hearing room
period if if I have it happen I'll eject
the individual is doing it Mr chairman
just for the record that was 20
seconds thank you very much
Leon thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Erica lean I
represent the town of dairy my first
year of my first term I sat on this
committee I was involved in the bill
drafting the EFA program and I did the
most recent update of the home school
laws um the original concern seems to be
that there needs to be a record keeping
for the EFA program anybody who takes a
Statewide takes a test reports it to the
EFA program and that goes up what this
bill does is it goes into the Statewide
testing that regards public schools that
is intended to allow this allow informed
decisions that can be made concerning
curriculum inservice education
instructional Improvement teacher
training resource allocation and
Staffing within our local public
districts adding this into the statute
is appropriate and non gerine to any
public any private school or home
educated students because this does not
deal with home educated students EFA
students or private schools this section
is about public schools adding this
language in is completely
counterproductive to the choices that
are allowed within the
state quite frankly um this language
does not work it creates mandates with
that are not included in the statutes
that oversee home education EFA phas or
private schools if you wanted to do this
and include this incorporation into all
those different programs it would have
to be drafted in an entirely different
way um however I would like you to take
a look and uh anybody who's interested
in the EFA performance to look at the
actual data that's reported out of that
because it's a new program it's been a
process in order to have those in and
have those reports however they seem to
be doing just as good a job reporting
that out as any of our local districts
so with that I am strongly opposed to
this all of these rooms and overflows
show you what happens when you threaten
the rights of parents to educate their
children especially those who don't take
State funds and I'd be happy to take any
questions are there any questions of
representa Le on yes representative
Tanner thank you thank you and thank you
for coming uh to testify today
representative uh chairman lad said that
there's four parts of um compulsory
education public school private school
home school and EFA does homeschool
break down into two groups one that that
is an EFA Homeschool Group and um that
therefore would have a unique pupil
identifier um versus homeschoolers that
don't accept any money from the state
well thank you for that question legally
if you take EFA funds it doesn't matter
where you go to school whether it's a
private school or if it's an allart
education that you're having at home you
are legally an EFA student under I think
it's
193f um it's an entirely different
statute than 193a which regulates home
educated students those are students who
do not have acid they notify their
agency and their parents are responsible
for their education and their curriculum
in order to show that they be able to
show that they are having progress they
have to either take a Statewide test uh
sorry take a standardized test it can be
I you can use the old California 90s
ones that worked for my husband and I
and that we use with our kids because we
understand what those measure or you can
have a portfolio review you also retain
a portfolio of your work and your
reading list
so there already are good guarantees for
those who are trying to look over a
parent shoulder in the case of an
educational neglect but those are not
reported up to the state it would be a
wholesale change in order to require
homeschool students to go take the same
standardized test at a public school and
it's a massive unfunded mandate if you
would have to have those kids come into
the school and take the test at the
local public school that would be a
tremendous cost to our local districts
and right now we're trying to make sure
that everything can be provided
appropriately yes go ahead representor
so I just want to I want to understand
that you can homeschool and take an EFA
or you can homeschool and not take an
EFA is that correct no you're not
homeschooling if you take an it's not
legally considered homeschooling if you
take I'll clarify that for everybody
here if you're a homeschool student and
you choose to take an EFA you are now an
EFA student not a h school student in
conjunction with compulsory
attendance for further questions
represent beler thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here to take my
question we've had a lot of sort of back
and forth and I think it's been a little
confusing about um what is an EFA versus
what is
homeschooling but the way I'm looking at
this and correct me if I'm wrong to see
if you read this the same way the very
first one of the first changes it says
this applies to all learning
environments and then lower in the bill
it says um home educated students shall
contact their local districts to
participate in the Statewide assessment
so isn't this really just neither here
nor there this is about all homeschool
students um thank you for that question
it actually goes beyond just all
students who learn at home whether
they're a 193a homeschooler or somebody
who takes an EFA this also goes to
private school students quite frankly if
you look at this it would also include
anybody in the Department of Corrections
I'm not sure if those are already
included in those it also does not allow
the freedom to opt out that's provided
to students in our local public schools
so you know quite frankly not only is it
poorly drafted it includes uh unfunded
mandate onto our local districts it's
also discriminatory because it doesn't
provide the same accommodations as we
have to our students in our Public
Schools further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you uh representative John
sers yes by way no protocol usually has
the uh sponsor waiting to come back
since you have such a long period of
time for Testimony would you allow the
sponsor to come back and sit down please
oh represent cascaden can come back she
just can't ask questions oh she wouldn't
yeah are you speaking for her no that's
decision representa sers welcome thank
you Mr chair I thank you committee I
represented sellers Grafton district 18
I represented the 107 towns of graft
about 17,000 residents I just wanted
when I started looking at this bill I
just want to started picking it apart
and I'm saying you know as as one of the
representatives just pointed out here it
says all learning environments when you
use that word
all now it gets very you know where do
we go do we go to court does the school
district say well it says all learning
environments you know so it says all
doesn't say some it says all the other
thing that I noticed in pointing out
here on line five it says in mathematics
at minimum so the the word at minimum or
at minimum there is my point is so do
they have to do
English reading mathematics now they now
this District says oh well we want you
to test in science uh we want you to
test now in history as well you know
again it's just saying at minimum so I
mean who makes that decision at minimum
and again was pointed out here it does
say which I've learned actually today
thank you for helping explain this it
does say home educated students and I
didn't realize efas were different than
home educated so that's interesting and
I'd have to look up and read up on that
myself to see what that now is but again
as the representative before me said
there's no opt out and it says these
these students shall that means they
have to there is no opt out our public
school has opt out but these kids don't
have opt out same thing with private
schools it says shall all right no if
butt they shall there's no opt out uh
situation for them as well the other
couple things I were thinking about here
I'm saying just to keep everybody in
mind our Public Schools they're failing
I mean about 50% of the kids are failing
when you when you take these tests and
you look at them you go on the doe
Report website and you can see they show
you the scores for for uh English Math
and Science and almost 50% are failing
if you're not in level three or four
you're failing all right up two minutes
all right thank you any questions are
there any questions of represent
sers not see any thank you very much
thank you okay at this point in time I'm
going to start down into this pile here
and so I'll call Michelle LVL and on
Deck it's Abigail
hole Michelle welcome thank you it's a
pleasure to be
back uh in the interest of time I'll
only read some excerpts I have one copy
for the uh records and I'll email you
the rest of my testimony for the record
my name is Michelle lvll and I'm the
director of Granite State Home Educators
an all volunteer nonprofit with over
16,000 members across the state I've
been involved in Broad education choice
and alternative initiatives for nearly
20 years
there is no compelling reason for this
bill I remind the committee that just
two years ago HB 1663 passed this
committee with a 19 to1 ought to pass
vote among other things HB 1663 created
a More Level Playing Field for home
educated children regardless of
Assessments the homeed statute RSA 193a
now says that independent homeschooled
children must do an in an annual
assessment and show quote Pro
commensurate with age ability and or
disability what has changed to mandate
these children now take the same
Statewide assessment that is
administered in their local public
schools I understand an amendment may be
offered to remove independent
homeschoolers from this heavy-handed
bill I would support such an amendment
however until it is introduced I cannot
make specific comments to it I caution
the committee that on any amendment that
requires participation in the Statewide
assessment however many public school
teachers abhor highstakes tests because
they are not good reflections of
achievement and take away valuable
learning time even the National educ
Education Association stated that public
education should quote think beyond the
bubble end quote regarding standardized
testing some States including Florida
Georgia and New York in bipartisan
efforts are rethinking their
standardized testing and graduation
requirements children are more than test
scores and there are other ways to have
accountability of government funded
education in 2 days the committee will
exec on hb610 remember the faces you see
in the audience today and remember the
compelling stories you're told please
vote this Bill itl thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
not see anything yes representative
Cornell thank you and thank you we
haven't seen you in ages so it's nice to
see you and I can't remember from HB
1663 you said that a report had to be
made and and I can't
remember who that goes to or what or
what it is because I in the old days I
remember as a guance council or
portfolio review or whatever and I know
that's changed and I can't remember what
happens now sure so incurrent statute H
uh house it's uh RSA 193a I believe it's
subsection five please correct me if I'm
wrong it's either five or six I think
six um it asks all independent unfunded
homeschoolers to still keep a portfolio
that includes a reading list and work
samples of whatever their child has been
doing that is their private property
it's retained by the family they also
must do some sort of annual assessment
and the Cho there are three broad
choices at the parents discretion it can
be a standardized test it can be a
portfolio review by a teacher or
something else that shows quote progress
commensurate with with age ability and
or disability all of that is retained by
the family and part of their child's
records so should they enroll in
something in their school and need to
show what their child has done to
qualify for a placement that is part of
their records that they could do they
could do that when they apply for dual
enrollment or any other program or any
other thing that that child moves on to
do it becomes essentially the uh
material for a transcript but it is
accountability to the parents because
they are the ones paying for it not the
state so it is the parents records
should there ever be need for that
information yes so these are the
independent homeschool students that do
not receive any money through efas or
anything else correct thank you further
questions from the committee not see any
thank you very much thank you so Abigail
Belmore followed by Aubrey fredman and
to thank you welcome welcome thank you
ABA bmore from Chester New Hampshire I
run homeschooling in new uh Chester New
Hampshire I'm also a volunteer with h
Granite State Home Educators with
Michelle um I'm actually here to be a
voice for the children um I've been
asking for the last few weeks what their
thoughts are on this for homeschoolers
that are unfunded huge words from them
they're big mad just you now they're
angry their anxiety at having to be in
an unknown area to be performing a test
they're being forced to take a test that
they are unknown to taking when they're
used to like a pfolio they're not
learning to test they're learning for
life skills they're learning for life
they don't stop at 18 they're being
taught to continue their education
they're mad they're upset they're scared
about taking a test in school being
supervised by an untrusted unknown
person or persons being in in a room
with kids that they don't know having
the anxiety of doing so sad that my
parents are being asked to take me
somewhere I've never been not right will
not answer the test mean why not cool no
fun not fair I test every year or I get
a portfolio every year why should I have
to go sit in a public school didn't the
government have anything else to do to
then bother us some kids are asking I
don't want to go in an unfamiliar
strange
projectors um nervous uncomfortable un
familiar others are I'd like privacy I
don't test well I need to be able to
take my
time I have disabilities learning is
hard for me why should I be
tested a
old ex homeschooled person he's now a
teacher he goes this is a violation of
my rights I wouldn't have taken it spoke
to my son he has issues with State
tested time tests we use the California
state test or have a qualified teacher
reveal our portfolio why should I have
to sit time pressures this is a reward
for the school not for
me um undermines and minimizes every
single reason we choose to homeschool
these are from children mind you not the
adults um they said we use different
programs than what the school uses we
don't use common core standards time's
up thank you any questions uh if you
have written testimony there this is
yours great thank you very much are
there questions from the committee
yes represent Hall thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I was
just curious um after hearing the prime
sponsor introduce the bill do you feel
comfortable or that it does not include
homeschoolers well as of right now as
it's written it states that
homeschoolers whether we take any type
of funding unfunded or funded that we
are being required to participate in our
Public Schools okay follow up yes so do
you if it were um I guess do you believe
that the amendment would come across
that the homeschoolers do well let me
let me rephrase that do you believe that
the prime sponsor does her intent was
not to include the home schools not as
written you know not as written but she
testified that okay thank you on the
same path do you believe that private
schools should be required as it stays
on the next line down from the lines 15
and 16 to 16 and 177 they're required to
participate do they take State funding
should holderness do it Kimble Union do
it do they take State funding do they
take our tax money I think you've asked
answer my question
yep repan
luno thank you Mr chair so just just
following on on that um uh what if um
what if this testing requirement either
being a Statewide test or a a national
uh um Norm reference test uh were to
apply to uh uh student
students uh basically EFA students they
take State funding right correct they're
using state tax dollars to fund their
program because they choose not to pull
it out of their own Pockets or give up
something that they don't want then they
are under the government standards why
not they're taking funds from the tax
pay payers or any program that it is set
aside for I'm technically putting tax
money in it's funding that somehow they
need to have accountability of course
because it's got down to the bottom of
accounting Alliance that you need to
know where the money is going why not
make sure that that child is actually
being tested appropriately for the
program that they're using I personally
have chosen not to choose to have my
children in a public studing in any form
in any time of their education and I
choose to test them or have them
reviewed as I see fit I don't have to
have a
review in terms of from the educational
board unless you guys ask me if I'm
following my letter of the law yeah I'll
show show you my totes have
fun thank you you have a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question just along that same line
although um homeschoolers that take efas
are called EFA students they're still
kind of doing the same program um and
I'm wondering if the assessment that's
available in the education Freedom count
statute that's not an assessment test
but a portfolio would then meet your
requirements sure if that's stated in
the law for their EFA you
know for being part of that program yes
that would qualify all right would you
be um um would you mind if they were uh
required to take assessments only would
that bother you no thank you repent
McDonald thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here along the same lines
of reasoning if this mandated that all
students
were in to take this test would do you
see that less students would choose to
in addition to a portfolio and achieve
the amazing things that they make in the
portfolio would there be less
portfolios as an unfunded homeschooler
I'm required to keep a portfolio
regardless if I use a standardized test
or not okay and the same goes I'm
assuming for the EFA loan they are
required to keep your portfolio also
correct yeah so a followup you'd have to
report twice one for the test and one
for the port folio it seems to be twice
as much am I correct I believe the EFA
loan that they are required
to put their testing portfolio whatever
it is that's required of them towards
whatever board is in charge of that
whereas me I'm not required to show
anyone unless somebody is in doubt that
I am educating my children correctly
that clarifies a lot thank you yes
further
questions thank you very
much uh Aubrey Freeman followed by Karen
Weeden Mr chair afternoon again yeah
okay Aubrey Friedman Bridgewater speak
in opposition to this bill um okay if as
as far as homeschoolers there should be
no question they are doing all the job
themselves incurring the expans not
being able to work a full-time job
whatever it might be so and actually
paying for other kids uh education too
so there should be absolutely no testing
requirement on them um and there
actually there already is that
evaluation 193 A6 part two has been
mentioned already so okay about this
whole
testing fancy scheme as was mentioned by
representative belart even if you had it
even just the EFA students alone the
ones who take the state money leave
alone the homeschoolers what is it
actually going to accomplish I mean we
see how the government schools do you
can pull up any school district or
individual school and see the
results yeah it's
transparent uh the results have been
lousy for years before Co after Co what
does it actually accomplished now $2.5
million do of taxpayer dollars this
would be an ongoing thing to um
Institute this whole
uh testing scheme that would apply
that's per the fiscal note to all the uh
EFA and I guess everybody says all
learning environments what would be
accomplished by it to be honest um I
just don't see the advantage and then
just the fact that every it's also
privacy issue too uh let's see it's uh
part one article 2B the New Hampshire
Constitution a right to privacy from
government intrusion you'd have to to
have a state uh assigned ID that's like
a a registry basically and a government
registry what could possibly go wrong
with that so I I definitely have
problems with that's a big privacy issue
um and that's basically it I don't think
this bill would actually accomplish
anything thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question do you realize that
if they take an FAA they have to have a
unique pupil identifier sassa with the
Department of Education with the
government well I guess if you take
State money then you're giving up a
little bit of privacy so I can kind of
understand that but that shouldn't apply
to the homeschoolers they should not
have to who don't take school yeah if
you take the money you give up a little
bit of privacy I I I think that's just
part of the uh the game I accept that
further questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you very much uh Karen
tol Amanda Weeden and then
Laura go
Gogan um also if Jennifer for can hear
me if there's any Mothers or fathers out
there with a young child they're holding
uh let's get those names so they can get
out of here if they need to get home get
kids to the afternoon na we have one in
this room right there I can to my right
welcome thank you chairman lad honorable
Representatives my name is Karen tol I'm
a resident of miramac New Hampshire I'm
a 24-year homeschooler I probably look
it and I'm also in leadership for
Granite State Home Educators but today I
wanted to talk to you not as a member of
leadership but just as a
taxpayer I'm really concerned about the
fiscal impact of this bill
representative cascaden I really
understand what you're trying to do with
accountability and I do appreciate that
but I don't think this is the way we're
adding millions of dollars to a program
that is already costing me tens of
millions and with our recent
expansion hundreds of millions
potentially we're disrupting our Public
Schools if we bring people into test we
know that our children are struggling
already in public schools imagine the
chaos When You Haul in the thousands of
Home Educators vac students private
school students and EFA students into a
local District who has to accommodate
them and then administer the tests and
then finally I'm sure you've heard it's
stressful for anyone who's not already
in the system further if you ask any
public school teacher what benefit are
we really getting out of these tests are
we serving our
students but I want to talk as a
taxpayer about accountability because if
you're spending my dollars on it I agree
with you they owe us some accountability
I don't think that we need a separate
piece of legislation for this I think
that we can accomplish it right within
194f the EFA law already they are
required to either have a nationally
standardized Norm reference test or take
the state Statewide student assessment
or complete a portfolio so would it be
possible to amend
194f to make for example if you really
want State testing for efas you could do
it right Within
second we can change how we're operating
the EFA right now they do have the
opportunity to submit assessment tests
however my understanding is it's just a
dialogue box on a form no one ever looks
at the actual results and we're doing it
on the honor System so just by
submitting the actual report the
committee may feel more comfortable with
the accountability of that student your
your time is up thank you sir thank you
very much for coming are there questions
from the
committee thank you appreciate it uh
Amanda
zuk good
afternoon my name is Amanda Weeden and
I'm a veteran homeschool mom from
Rochester New Hampshire I'm a longtime
leader in Granite State Home Educators
and Christian Home educator of New
Hampshire and Southern Maine I'm also a
special needs homeschooling advocate in
New Hampshire I've served on heak The
Homeschool um home education advisory
council is co-chair and I am an unfunded
traditional RSA 193 home educator to be
clear none of my children are or will
ever be in any other educational pathway
those available in New Hampshire those
of us who want nothing to do with
government money and the strong push for
extreme unnecessary oversight have now
been forced to come up with terms like
unfunded traditional RSA 193a
homeschoolers because the EFA
educational pathway legislators and
organizations don't understand the
difference to be honest I don't want to
be here right now poorly written
legislation started this mess and by the
looks of it it's going to continue ad
nauseum in other attempts to regulate
the EFA program I've been silent because
frankly who can keep up
Not Me Home Educators who understand the
implications of the EFA program on our
freedom in New Hampshire were pushed out
of the conversation from the beginning
and this the bill that was literally
ransomed in the budget bill was sloppy
that bill was sloppy this bill is also
sloppy it's interesting to me that an
entire side of the aisle where I usually
land myself has hitched its wagon into a
program that's not transparent with
proponents who benefit immensely either
financially or politically the pattern
in other states that we're seeing it's
the same Trend in the legislates that
have these types of programs and people
are starting to wake up to the long-term
term implications that they will produce
so I could go on about how disastrous
the EFA bill has been for home education
in New Hampshire but my needing to be
here right now is proved
positive I want legislators to do better
I want our representatives to consult
stakeholders who do not benefit
financially or politically from outcom
up now do you have written testimony
there for us that you could share with
the committee
absolutely if you could drop it off with
representative beler over there then
it'll be passed around to the chair or
speak the clerk any questions from the
committee thank you very
much uh Laura
Britman good afternoon my name is Laura
gawran I am a homeschooling unfunded
homeschooling parent uh living in tuon
Boro I come here today to oppose House
Bill
1610 uh I should also note that I am
currently a certified teacher I hold a
certification in the state of
Connecticut and I have 10 years of
teaching
experience uh even as a public school
teacher I was not in favor of
standardized assessments and now as a
homeschooling mother absolutely I am not
standardized assessments don't give you
a depiction a proper depiction of what a
child knows and what that child's
individual strengths
are as a homeschooling parent I document
my daughter's growth through a portfolio
that shows her individual growth it
shows her
strs and there is so much more that we
do in homeschooling Beyond reading and
math I don't want to be well I'm
unfunded so I'm I'm going to speak for
my uh EFA counterparts and I support
them and not having to do standardized
tests either because we choose to to
teach our children at home because we
don't want to give them standardized
assessment I've seen what that leads to
I'm not interested in
it
that's all I have for today thank you
very much are comments from or questions
from the
committee that's thank you very much uh
next person is Sarah
sford I'm Sarah zck I live in Salsbury
New Hampshire and I'm a 193 a
homeschooling mother of four I'm here to
vehemently oppose this
bill my husband Marcus and I knew we
would be homeschoolers before the birth
of our first child we decided this
because we knew that no stranger could
ever possibly be as invested in our
children in the future of our family as
we
are as parents we know that no stranger
could ever possibly understand our
children their learning styles or their
individual needs better than we do
as homeschoolers we enjoy the freedom to
create a curriculum that reflects our
fam's values and to cherry-pick all
materials and any instructors from
outside our family who best support our
goals since our children possess strong
vocabularies we chose a phonics based
reading program because they see both of
their parents working around their house
we chose a self-paced math program based
on conceptual intuition built from
practical
examples we are a Jewish Family a
portion of our curriculum is dedicated
to Jewish studies we carefully selected
a Jewish studies instructor with
children in the same age bracket who we
felt would be best suited to approach
cultural historical and Theological
subject matter in a manner which Best
Suits us my point is that time and
effort go into building both a
curriculum and Outsourcing assistance as
needed no two homeschooling families are
precisely the same just as no two
students are precisely the same
homeschoolers as a whole do share one
important quality with the private and
parochial school students who this would
also who would also be affected by this
bill regardless of the philosophy that
motivates them or the pedagogical
approaches they employ across all
categories of students in all types of
learning environments the fames this
bill wishes to scrutinize perform better
than the public school students your
time is up it ignores okay thank you
very much Sarah where do I pardon me yep
okay right over there any questions from
the committee thank you
again
uh Karina
Reitman uh lens Sanford then Lisa Cody
Lisa had to leave
this is not here
Garcia well that's a young
one not quite homeschooled yet but you
know well everything you need to know is
learning in kindergarten you're getting
pretty
close learning to uh roll over so far so
that's that's our lesson at the moment
yeah my name is Karina Ryman and I live
in Bradford New Hampshire and I I I
homeschooled my children without any
state
funding I want to say that to me this
bill is basically a bureaucratic
intrusion into uh something that we
homeschoolers are already
doing um it seems we've met many people
of I think all homeschooling families
have made many people who seem to have
some sort of grudge against
homeschooling uh for some reason and uh
I think they try to make it go away in
some way or make it look as much as
possible as public schools and um this
bill would basically be doing one one
more step in in that direction created
this sort of rigid and state directed
uniformity as opposed to the choice that
we uh homeschooling families appreciate
so much and the reason that we do this
uh I have two older children besides
this one who I'm homeschooling I have
been a teacher for over 20 years I have
master's degree in physics and moreover
I am the mother of my children so I
think I know best what they need and how
to evaluate what they are learning uh
this bill would basically put that
decision in the hands of a bunch of
bureaucrats I don't see how that would
be beneficial for anyone I have also
taught in schools and like others have
already said even School teachers think
standardized tests are terrible and uh
they are useless moreover because
children's knowledge is not really
represented in the results of these
tests so I'm not sure why we would want
to include even more children in
something that is already
useless
um the way to educational success is
most likely not through even more
regulation if regulation was the answer
Public Schools would be doing amazing
and um they're
not so I just I think I want to urge you
you to deem this bill inexpedient to
legislate it's adding absolutely nothing
and creating more complications and
something that already has a solution
because we are already required to
evaluate our children thank you very
much for coming today from your very
very busy
schedule any questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
much uh Larin
Sanford Jacqueline Garcia and then
Virginia
Avery
good afternoon hi hi I had to cut this
down in two minutes so please bear with
me um hello my name is Larin Sanford of
gtown New Hampshire and I'm an EFA
student the efas have added to our
education with more learning
opportunities and experiences for my
siblings and I for the past few years
we've been going to a learning Co-op
once a week I've taken public speaking
there which I'm putting into practice
right now and I'm currently taking a
class called seminar topics which covers
a variety of subjects and through which
we can explore possible career paths one
of the topics we covered was on Aviation
and I'm now considering getting my
pilot's license in a few years a pilot
volunteered some time with me as a
result and I discovered a love for
flying my point in all of this is not
only to share some of the opportunities
we've had with the EFA program but to
show you that there is so much learning
to be done done outside of a public
school setting we don't follow the exact
timeline or the same curriculum as a
public school student does my brothers
and I take math and language arts
lessons as well as the other required
EFA School subjects with online and book
resources and we do quizzes and tests
for these
subjects as an EFA family we also
already take approved standardized tests
and submit those through the CSF program
at the end of the year to add the NH
State assessments on top of all this
would be redundant and a waste of
taxpayers money you shouldn't lump all
the educational Pathways under this bill
over the years our family has been part
of public school a traditional home
education and now the EFA program and we
know they are all covered under their
own rules and regulations with the state
this is how it should remain this past
year I've also developed an interest in
politics and I've been given
opportunities to go to events like the
first in nation Leadership Summit meet
presidential candidates face to face and
have signed waved for several state and
local elections I couldn't do these
things without the freedom and
flexibility we have now in conclusion I
told my mom that in when I am old enough
I might run for state state reps so that
I can continue to protect educational
freedoms and school choice in our Live
Free or Die State of New Hampshire
please vote against hb610 thank you
thank you very very much want to run for
[Laughter]
governor are there any questions from
the
committee I would just ask your age uh
14 great and um I think there's a State
Rep from gos down here so she's heard
the
warning
yeah thank you so much thank you yes
Jacqueline Garcia Virginia Avery and
prman yeah
yep
good afternoon my name is Jacqueline
Garcia um we are a non-funded homeschool
family from Meredith New Hampshire I am
here today to ask you to oppose hb610
this bill is too broad and infringes on
our rights as homeschoolers in New
Hampshire the wording of this bill is
not specific to allowing home educated
students to be opted out by their
parents yet clearly gives that option to
public school students per RSA 193 A6 we
are already required by law as
homeschoolers to do a yearly assessment
and so requiring us to participate in a
Statewide assessment is redundant and
unnecessary home education is the
responsibility of the parents not the
government and public
officials this bill would make New
Hampshire the highest regulated state
for
homeschooling homeschool freedom in New
Hampshire is a major reason so very many
families including my own have relocated
to this beautiful State and according to
RSA 193 A6 our assessment results are
private and this bill would violate that
right so I'm asking you today to please
oppose this Bill thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you um Virginia
Avery Maran
Martell hello my name is Virginia Avery
and I'm from Deerfield I'm a New
Hampshire certified educator who has 15
years of experience teaching in both
public and private schools I am
currently a parent and a home educator
to my three children as well as a home
school portfolio evaluator I am speaking
in opposition um to HB 1610 uh one of
the biggest things uh that I want to
point out is that current parents of
public school children uh have the
option of exempting their students from
this testing and if this were to pass
home education parents would not be
given the same opportunity and I believe
that there is no reason that any student
choosing an educational pathway outside
of the public school system should have
more restrictive regulations than
traditional
students um also uh currently homeschool
families um have the ability to contact
their school to take these State um
testing so if they feel um that
participating in this test would be
better inform their instruction um they
can contact their school to do so uh it
would not be beneficial to mandate this
it would also be illogical to burden the
public school with such an outrageous
task when their time and resources will
be best used to serve the current
student population the bill is requiring
all students to enter the public school
to take this assessment and I want you
to take a moment to think about what
that would actually look like students
who have never foot um set foot in a
public school before special education
students students with anxiety sensory
processing disorder autism Behavior
challenges just to list a few
um the needs of these students cannot be
recognized by the public school since
they're ineligible for an IEP unless
they are fully enrolled they will now be
required to take a test with zero
supports or
accommodations I want to paint a picture
of what that would look like for one of
my daughters in her home education she
received specialized curriculum and
instruction tailoring to her individual
needs um some of which include speech um
OT working with a child psychologist
focusing on her anxiety if she required
to take this test you could expect there
to be crying crying screaming kicking
flipping of chairs attempts to escape
the room and likely refusal to enter the
building to begin with um and so I'd
like to just end by saying how could
this mandated test be in the best
interest of these children's well-being
and educational progress thank you thank
you very much represent
Damon thank you thank you for being here
and taking my question could you just
inform us a bit more you comment about
being a portfolio evaluator um can you
tell us how that works yes um so one of
the choices for um the RSA 193 um a
homeschoolers is they could get their
portfolio evaluated by a licensed um
teacher so I meet with parents we
discuss goals we review their work
samples um and through their work
samples they need to provide um evidence
that they're showing progress um conasur
with age and ability um and through this
meeting and through look I look through
their work samples um and then I will
confirm with my credentials that they
have indeed um met the requirements and
have shown progress over their Year's
work thank you I got a question for you
too as a a person that's taught before
in the public schools I would assume was
public ver private either one yeah um do
you believe that the Statewide
assessment as we give in this state will
be aligned with your homeschooling
program and the objectives outcomes you
expect at home I do not agree um as a
homeschooler we are not obligated um by
law to follow the same guidelines and
the same standards that the schools use
um parents have autonomy to decide um
what standards and uh what guidelines
they would like to follow in what
curriculum um and so the odds of it
aligning with what public schools are
doing um are slim while there might be
some that may align um there are many
that I believe will not thank you very
much forther the questions from the
committee thank you thank
Freeman and uh Louise marel
Levante welcome hi I'm Marian Freeman
from Sutton New Hampshire I'm a
traditional unfunded home education
parent under RSA 193a and I would ask
you to oppose this bill I'm going to
give you an example of something that
happened while my son was in public
school and uh took part in an assessment
that was computer
generated my understanding is that in
order for um tests to have True Value
the students need to have been taught
the material the questions need to
reflect that material appropriately and
the student needs to sit for the test in
an authentic manner in other words try
their
best so my son took a math assessment
and was so stressed out that uh he
almost shut down at one moment he
decided to follow something he had heard
his mother say once which was when I was
in college if we didn't know the answer
we usually picked C and it worked out
okay and I didn't know that he had done
this when I got his math results he
scored average ability in math for grade
seven which from what I knew of him I
thought was a reasonable assessment then
I got the information from the math
teacher that told me which areas he
needed to work on in his weaknesses they
made no sense to me because I knew
everything that he knew so I went to him
and said said can you tell me what
happened that day during the testing
because we were new to New Hampshire and
new to the school district and
everything was new he explained to me
that he was stressed he didn't know what
to do he was afraid he wasn't going to
have time to complete and so he picked
this nugget out of his memory and
generally speaking picked C for the rest
of the test he finished the test in
record time because he didn't really
take time to review the
questions and the teachers and the
guidance counselors didn't note that he
had finished the test in about 15
minutes unfortunately your time is up so
all I want to say is these results from
any of these assessments are not helpful
to the students and they are a colossal
waste of time and money and I don't
support it and I ask you to also not
vote for it thank you thank you very
much other questions from the committee
thank you
uh Louise Mar Co marle and Kristen lante
and
then uh Joel
green I
guess good afternoon my name is Lise
Martell and I'm a voting resident of
Berlin
hi I oppose hb610 all of the reasons
that I've get written down have already
been mentioned I will leave these two
copies with you um the only this is an
RSA 194f issue and it that should be
addressed there it doesn't really need
to be touching homeschool families and I
thank you for this opportunity to bring
my family to yet another off to speak to
you about this it's a learning
experience my kids got all dressed up my
son wor his new TI we're good you know
pleas I'm glad you're enjoying
it and expedient to legislate all the
way down from Berlin I used to live in
Rumford oh on the other side yeah
in that area
okay can I get thank you okay Joel uh
then uh Kristen lante and then Matt
sutherton
y
know oh so who Who's On Deck you're in
the hole
right Ted Williams
STS hello my name is Kristen leani from
Berlin New Hampshire I have four
children that are currently using the
EFA accounts to homeschool I am here to
oppose hb610 homeschooling was never the
plan until my son entered Berlin public
school and had a very rough kindergarten
year he was new three months of the
curriculum after nine months and Berlin
wanted to move him to first grade that's
when we pulled him from public school we
have two more kids and then come to
Child Number Four he was placed with us
at eight months of age in foster care
and we adopted him when he was three
between trauma and medical diagnosis
multiple doctors recommended public
school for the services and consistent
environment we debated and ultimately
decided to do half days at Berlin and
half day EFA student home with me since
even after preschool at Min mounties 2
days a week he would come home and
violently rock on our couch trying to
regulate he was considered a level five
for special education requiring a one
toone perah from the moment he got off
the special ed bus until he was back on
the bus 2 and a half hours later he can
be a Flight Risk when overwhelmed
however Berlin did not follow his IEP
they were legally required to follow
they thought bouncing a child with
special needs between all four
kindergarten classes so his one toone
Aid could cover other students with
their shortage of pairs was acceptable
they also found it acceptable to send
his one-on-one Aid to lunch he's only
there for two and a half hours while he
was on the playground in no one to cover
that time period none of which was
communicated to us until my son got off
the bus one day saying he couldn't play
on the playground because he didn't have
snow pants which were actually in his
background that is how I found out his
one-on-one was with another student and
he was on his own without the help he
needed and it was happening over the
past month often so if burlin could not
pro provide the proper staff when
legally required how are the schools
going to have the staff to come the
requirements for the testing or am I
supposed to drop my Flight Risk child
off to a test and just hope when I go
back to pick him up that he is there
safe and receive the commendations he
would
need let the schools focus on those
children and the parents of private
schools focus on the children we have
chosen to educate since sometimes those
reasons are because the public school
failed them and sending them back for a
test with zero purpose is not acceptable
your your time is up thank you are there
any questions from the committee from
Berlin question that's
right that's true that's true you got
me okay so any questions from the
committee thank you very much you're
welcome thank
you okay
okay Matt Southerton and then
Beth all right
good afternoon um my name is Joel gruy
um I'm the executive director of
homeschool legal defense Association
action the policy armor of hslda um we
have about 100,000 uh homeschool
families Nationwide we are the world's
largest homeschool advocacy organization
um on behalf of those families and along
with our allies Gran State Home
Educators and Catholics United for home
education hsld strongly opposes hb610 in
its entirety this bill as drafted is not
about educational freedoms accounts it's
a in fact a high stakes test mandate
the bill would put New Hampshire at this
point below New York and Massachusetts
as the most hostile States for home
education in the United States uh
representative pelli was correct on
January 29th when she said that the
testing mandate in this bill would cause
concern for home education families uh
we do have serious concerns home
education thrives in its freedom to
recognize and respond to the uniqueness
of each child as we've heard here today
as someone who was home educated myself
and who educates my own children there's
a breathtaking amount of diversity and
customization that exists within a
family um for how we teach each kid how
we're able to accommodate the needs of
each kid between the parents and the
children the New Hampshire law already
requires annual testing for
homeschoolers as you well know uh this
is no need of changing this testing
mandate would require homeschool
students to take Statewide assessments
built around the state s sols in a sense
just like public school students this is
actually inferior to current law which
is a nationally Norm reference
standardized achievement test published
and scored by an independent third party
the replacement would preparis be of
Criterion assessment test judging a home
School student's ability to regurgitate
information based on public school
learning objectives Public School
teachers already consistently complain
that they are forced to teach to the
test at the expense of actual education
this testing manate would drag
homeschoolers into that existing
Quagmire and that undercuts the secret
sauce that makes homeschooling Thrive
with a back door implementation
implementation of State mandated
curriculum trust New Hampshire citizens
to act responsibly and love their
children and teach them well don't view
them with suspicion which this bill
communicates now Live Free or Die means
something in New Hampshire and I trust
in this bill it still does thank you
much for your time I urge you to vote
against hb610 but I would be happy to
answer any questions the committee has
any questions from the committee thank
you very much Matt I'm not going to do
door
oh I was the one responsible for this
you guys should have them at your desk
you hello good afternoon Angela thank
you for having us here um my name is
Angela Turka I'm from do New Hampshire I
am currently homeschooling three kids
one of which is still unregistered
because he's only three
but he still gets homeschool Services um
we are unfunded of course and um I
oppose this bill and I'm asking you to
do so as well um mandating testing of
any sort does not help our children to
learn as I know people have mentioned
teaching to a test doesn't actually
teach doesn't allow for that flexibility
to really learn like our kids came down
here to conquer it and they're looking
at the buildings like holy moly and that
is a learning experience just looking
around and being able to do that that's
not teaching to a test if you're
teaching to a test you don't have time
for that
stuff and it creates anxiety and can
cause uh feelings of inadequacy and
inferiority if they're doing less than
average when kids have
struggles um one of my daughters has had
a speech impediment and has taken her
years to overcome that and so she's
behind on reading but she's catching up
but if she's taking a reading test by
state standards and she sees that she's
behind she's going to feel defeated
already and that's not fair to our
students when we're we're waiting for
them to catch up and we're learning and
teaching them at their own
pace um there is no language in this
bill that allows for difference is in
any learning abilities as you can see I
have a son with Down syndrome and how is
he supposed to be able to adapt that
without any kind of help
or anything when there's no language to
protect him it also set uh infringes on
our familiar rights as we choose to be
separate from the public school
education for uh system this forces
families to participate in a system they
do not have a desire to be a part
of even if it's just to receive a
student ID number some of us are opposed
to
that the state does not
need the uh the pupil range our pupil's
range of learning for homeschooled
children the data gathered from home
educated children cannot and should not
have an effect on improving Ed uh
instruction and learning for those
within the public school system your
your time is up oh wow that was quick it
goes by quickly so far any questions are
there any questions no okay thank you I
know that when I bring the grandkids
down here at 5 years old they say look
papa there's the golden Castle and you
know so they they get something out of
do okay uh Matt do you want to come up
now
I juam okay and then Samantha
Marbury
uh hello again Matt Southerton for
children scholarship fund is is this on
I can't tell um anyway so we oppose this
bill as written we we believe that
current law is the right way to go it
provides families and parents the most
flexibility to choose the the the
different option or method that they
want to use to comply with the law that
is best for them one of the unintended
consequences that I'm really worried
about so as I've been in this position
I've learned that a number of um
families that have students with special
needs actually prefer the portfolio
evaluation because they believe that
that's just the way that they can best
measure growth for their students so
that really would concern me if we
changed that um obviously current law
provides the most flexibility and I do
have some metrics if you're interested
in those from 2022 and
2023 uh 69% of the students in the EFA
program chose a standardized test uh 30%
of the students in the EFA program uh
met that obligation with the uh student
portfolio so that roughly 1% of parents
chose the Statewide assessment thank you
Matt do you have those metrics available
for us I do I can I can email those to
the committee yes I appreciate it okay
any questions from the committee
no yes representative Boni thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question and responding to to my emails
giv the information um if if this if
something was passed that affected uh
students receiving the EFA accounts um
you're saying that you already are
collecting some information of students
that are taking standardized tests would
it be would there be a a way to make
that information publicly
available
okay in terms of sheer number so we're
we're prohibited by law from sharing any
P pii right pii so what we do when we
when we send this information to the
Department of Education we're required
to send them aggregated data so that's
why I can give you yes I can give you
the sheer numbers the the absolute
numbers in each
method okay so what you're saying is you
can provide the aggregate information to
the Department of Education uh for the
testing data yes yes okay thank
you aggregated numbers and correlated
with the number of students that are in
that aggregate correct okay represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you Mr Southerton is that information
being reported out um by the um
education department right
now I I would not know that's just we
send them the
data I don't know if it's posted online
or not all right and and and a followup
so that's so that data has been sent to
them for each of the that is that period
so
yeah that's my understanding and then um
this year students will start to
re-qualify in July uh they'll have until
July 15th to send us one of those three
methods and then we'll have you know
it's always a year look back okay and
final followup is there is there
anything in the in 194f that would um
prohibit the department from um
publishing that data the same way they
do for public
schools uh yeah I mean not that I'm
aware of as long for an aggregate yeah
that's I'm saying it's the same way in
public schools so and I think again I
think that'll probably be one of the
pieces in our annual report that we're
going to be you know we're going to
create an annual report give a look back
at the um EFA program each year so that
if you do have data that we can share
with you please let us know uh you know
if you find that helpful and we'll
include that in the board obviously
thank thank you you're welcome any
further questions for Mr San thank you
very much thanks uh
Beth Samantha Marberry
and Megan
Schmidt
yeah um quickly I will pass from
speaking seeing that all the points I
was going to make today um time is
ticking have been um brought forth
eloquently I strongly oppose uh the bill
I think it the language is poorly
written and it would also affect
homeschool Educators as well as EA
students so thank you thank
you
Smith Marberry uh Megan Schmidt uh
Jessica
Wilder they may be in another room I'm
hallway several weeks ago when we had a
horrific rainstorm we had an inch of
there
okay are are you
uh
hallway hi yes um I'm Samantha Marbury
I'm a homeschool mom of four from
wolfboro New Hampshire um I just want to
say I'm opposed to this bill I'm not
going to continue on because everybody's
pretty much covered everything that i'
would like to say um I also have a
letter that uh you guys should already
have that you can read uh with my
opinions but I did just want to say that
um you know if if everyone is looking at
us as how we're using tax fund you know
tax money uh taxpayer dollars I just
think we should also be looking at the
school systems to see you know if
they're failing what is the consequence
for that if if we're paying $20 ,000 per
student annually where's that money
going and what are the uh what are the
benefits of that and so if everybody's
concerned about what homeschoolers are
doing I think maybe we should be looking
at those big organizations first uh
thank you thank you very much are there
any
schmith hello hi my name is Megan
Schmidt I'm a resident of conquered and
I am a traditional homeschooler who does
not receive any funding for doing so as
it stands this bill would subject my
four children to be forced into
standardized testing a method that I who
arguably know my children best can tell
you would not be an accurate example of
the knowledge that they have this bill
is poorly written redundant in many ways
due to RSA
193a and a violation of homeschoolers
rights especially when many of us here
today have left public schools for the
curriculum or standardized tests so I
ask you to please vote itl on 1610 thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee thank you for
waiting uh Jessica
blasic good afternoon thank you
committee for allowing me the
opportunity to speak my name is Jessica
Seaman I'm a resident of Dairy New
Hampshire a homeschooling mom on under
the RSA 193a traditional unfunded
homeschooling and I also maintain my New
Hampshire teacher certification here in
the state I do that particularly so that
I can legally provide homeschool
portfolio evaluations for homeschoolers
in our state these families have
established a relationship with me over
several years so that we can evaluate
their progress Year bye through the EB
and flow of the programs curriculums and
techniques that the parents are using to
address their students changing needs or
Dynamic needs for throughout the years
these evaluations are a rich discourse
between the parent and myself as we are
looking over their portfolio and it
allows a deep understanding of the
progress the student has made during
that year I wholeheartedly believe that
for some students that rich education
that I see occurring in these very
personalized educational Pathways might
not be accurately reflected on a rigid
standardized fill in the bubble test
that's very concerning to me parents
would have to put much of that beautiful
comprehensive education that they're
doing aside in order to teach to the
test just that their student would do
well on paper and that's a sad option
this will be especially detrimental to
students who have any level of test
anxiety throwing even a neurotypical
child into a completely unknown
environment and asking them to perform
very well in a test is is laughable at
best and cruel at worst so much of
current education pushes for
individualization of instruction so why
take away the freedom for
individualization of evaluation as well
hb610 also allows the parents of public
school students to opt them out from
this standardized testing format but
that opt out is not afforded to the
other educational Pathways and that is
discriminatory I urge you to urge um itl
I urge you to vote itl on hb610 thank
you for the opportunity of speaking with
you today thank you very much other
questions from the
committee not see thank you very much if
there are any parent parents and any of
the other rooms that may have children
in public schools that are getting out
and need to be at the bus stop to pick
kids up yes would you please come
forward and we want to get you out of
here so you can get them pick the kids
up there's one right
here yeah have to let us know your name
so we can sort through the cards yes my
name is paa
gon go ahead hello thank you for the
opportunity to speak here today my name
is paa Vasquez gallon I'm from Salsbury
New Hampshire and I am a homeschool
mother to five children for the last
nine years I am also an immigrant I am
indigenous I am Latina and I am an EFA
educator as well the notion that our
family is freeloading off of the state
and not making sacrifices in order to
accept state funding in order to offer
our children resources for their
education is elitist and and frankly
insulting my family has sacrificed
everything we have sacrificed our
country my culture my
language family everything also that my
children can have freedom and
opportunities beyond what we have ever
had I urge you to vote no on hb610 as an
EFA educator our family already
participates in standardized testing and
it is already uploaded to the portal
that is required per the existing
requirements of receiving the EFA funds
I have three children with special needs
one of them with a genetic disorder who
require significant amount of special
education the EFA allows our children to
have opportunities that would not be
available to them otherwise such as
speech therapy occupational therapy
Aviation camps and other wonderful
resources that we have been able to do
our children recently finished
standardized testing and for my one
child it took her 14 hours spread out
for the last 3 days with me reading
every single question to her as you can
imagine this would be an unnecessary
burden to the public schools especially
to Salsbury Elementary School which is
the district that we are in that has 63
students currently in addition of five
more children is a 133% increase to them
and a 300% increase in special education
resources to them 14 hours for one child
9 hours for the other and 8 hours for
the other child of individual attention
my one child with a genetic disorder
also has a medical condition and the
individualized attention the
individualized requirements are required
per her doctor per her psychologist per
her psychiatrist so this is not
something that would be optional for the
school to provide it would be mandatory
otherwise it would be discri
I urge you to vote no thank you thank
you very much any questions from the
committee not see you thank you very
much uh Jamie Wilder uh Melissa blasic
and Kayla
look good afternoon good afternoon
Representatives my name is JMA Wilder
from campon New Hampshire I'm the mother
of five children and have homeschooled
my children and sent two of them to
Hollis Brook line upper elementary
middle school and high school I oppose
hb610 the claim is that the bill will be
used to identify a pupil's range of
learning and yields objective data to
use an improving instruction and
learning it would be
impossible to assess my children for
improvements because besides English
language arts reading and Mathematics my
children are taught complex culinary
arts Maple syruping beekeeping gardening
starting from seeds building framing
whittling mechanical drama music theory
personal finance just to list a few I am
confident that my teaching surpasses the
level of learning of the public private
or charter schools that is why I
homeschool if you were to test my
children on Common Core math they would
not recognize the ridiculous questions I
would be confident for the most of the
adults in this room that's also true we
live in a society where many teenagers
can't count change back to you but will
not acknowledge the harm this curriculum
is causing my tax dollars go to the
school district even though I receive no
financial support or resources from the
district or state it appears that this
bill is being used to keep money in the
public schools instead of allowing
parents to choose what is best for their
children I believe that this is a
gateway to control P private school
school choice and home school curriculum
when my children were in public school
the testing scores had dropped over over
onethird one year after covid the
assistant superintendent blamed the DNA
of the parents for the decline they
refused to consider lockdowns mandates
and remote learning on the decline
homeschoolers did not have a loss of
learning it is common knowledge that
teachers are required to teach to the
test if you are concerned with the level
of learning you should look into the
consequences of the decisions made by
the public school Educators over the
last four years this bill is going to
cost taxpayers Untold spending and will
not improve education in the public
private school choice or homeschooling
homes your thank you very much good
timing uh any questions from the
committee good luck up there in Campton
thank you we got our dog groomed up
there yeah it's muddy up there right now
okay thank you not seeing any more
questions we
have Melissa bless and kayin look and
Sarah sh sh
shower shower I guess it
is good afternoon thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Melissa blasik I'm here representing
rebuild NH uh rebuild opposes both the
intent and the consequences of hb610 um
there's been a lot of testimony today
about sort of the uh the all learning
environment so I'll I'll uh Focus my
testimony on as it would apply to EFA
students uh Reb has supported education
Freedom accounts as a means of giving
underprivileged children and families
more educational options outside of the
public school system currently EFA
students are required to submit an
end-year evaluation standardized test of
their choice or they can send their
child to a registered and approved
Private School uh standardized tests are
meant to gauge the efficiency of the
curriculum Public School curriculums are
now based in common core and tests have
been modified to reflect that curriculum
we are all aware that teacher regularly
teach to the test families who choose
EFA as an option are looking for
something different than what the public
schools are currently offering parents
who take their children out of public
school should not be required to tailor
their curriculum or their private
schools curriculum to match what is
being taught in public schools while I
understand the desire for an objective
standard to which to hold all taxpayer
funded education I don't believe that
such a metric exists and in the absence
of such an objective metric I don't
believe it is fair to demand one set of
taxpayer funded education have strings
attached while public schools have no
real Benchmark at which poor performance
loses funding thank you thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee not see any thank you uh kayn
KY
not
seeing kayn look is kayin look here she
left uh how about Sarah
shower there
great thank you members of the committee
afternoon good afternoon my name is
Sarah schaer I'm from stod New Hampshire
and I'm here today in opposition to
House Bill
1610 I'd like to start just briefly by
concurring with the many previous
speakers that have shared the many flaws
in this bill I agree that has very poor
broad sweeping language the execution
and the attent are not very clear as it
stands written I do see this as a direct
attack on parental rights and as it has
been mentioned having students take a
test that their specific curriculum has
not prepared them for is not by any
means a fair assessment of their
education but what I would really like
to share today today is my personal
story because I'm a homeschool graduate
my parents um had me attend kindergarten
in public and after that they decided
they could do better and they did I had
a very full Rich wonderful education I'm
so thankful for the sacrifices they made
I received curriculum and education that
was personalized to me and to my
strengths and to my weaknesses I'm quite
certain at some point I would have
struggled with a standardized test but
my parents weren't required to send me
to unfamiliar location to be
administered a test that my curriculum
didn't prepare me for and so when I
struggled they re-evaluated we made
adjustments tried a new curriculum until
I had success again my home education
has served me very very well in life and
more important than my experience
because to be honest high school and
college was a long time ago I'm here
today because now I'm a mother my
husband and I have two very bright
daughters four-year-old and almost
2-year-old who we intend to homeschool
we've already started doing preschool at
home and my daughter is thriving in
these earliest parts of her education
it's a joy but I want to have those same
opportunities for my children I am so
eager and excited to provide that level
of individualized education for my girls
my parents moved here in 2006 to find a
state that would support the opportunity
for them to provide more educationally
to their children and I'm here today to
ask you to uphold that state for me for
the Next Generation for my children
so that I may also provide that to them
so I'm asking you to please vote in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1610 thank you thank you very much a
wonderful story thank you yeah further
questions from the committee thank you
ksky and then Michelle roacher and
Audrey Bowen
I
paron we'll get
there hi hello my name is emosi I live
in we and I'm here today to speak in
opposition of House Bill
1610 I am a homeschool graduate and I
feel my education has made all the
difference in my life instead of my
education being focused on test
performance I was given an
individualized education with curriculum
and subject matter that worked for
me my family has always been independent
and unfunded and we have participated in
annual
assessments I was given the opportunity
to learn for the sake of learning for
growth and personal development not
pressure to perform on a
test I am here today to ask you to
preserve that learning opportunity for
current and future homeschooling
children by voting itl on House Bill
1610 thankk you thank you very much uh
have you do you have written testimony
there I don't have any extra copies
unfortunately could you submit the one
that you did put it in the record uh
I've written on it if that's all right
okay thank you the clerk will take it
anyways she get perfect any questions
any questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you very much thank you
yeah
Larry hi hello my name is Michelle
roacher I am a homeschooling mom of five
kiddos our oldest graduated two years
ago and our second will graduate this
year um we are a 193a unfunded
homeschooling family in
barington I have heard so many families
speaking to the many reasons why this is
a very very poorly written bill but I'm
going to speak to the fiscal note for
those that might not care about the
personal
stories representative cascaden promoted
this bill as a way to track the progress
of EFA students EFA students as you've
already heard from the CSF have to
submit that progress to the CSF and it's
submitted to the state in an aggregate
form
this would require those students to
submit to a second
test putting a burden on the district
schools to administer it representative
cascaden has spoken to say that the
money is what she's worried about yet
she's caused more spending in the
execution of it thank
you are there any questions from the
committee when you said a couple of
graduated already Yes did they take the
SAT or no we did not participate in the
SAT we do review of our work okay so my
next question is when you're applying to
colleges do they ask for anything like
that our oldest has not chosen to use uh
the college system at this time but as
my understanding to be that there are
many uh well-received uh homeschooling
uh applicants to many Nationwide
universities thank you thank you
uh next one is
Audrey Boden B bodden and Lydia o
Allen hello hi my name is Audrey Bowden
and I am a resident of dairy I am a mom
a small business owner and a student of
political science I will graduate in May
I'm currently an EFA homeschooling
parent and a lot of what I have to say
has already been pointed out to the
committee
but in efforts to with stain from being
an echo chamber I want to kind of point
out some of the things that a few people
before me have have touched upon but not
really founded upon So currently there
are stipulations for receiving the EFA
fund and a lot of those stipulations
have to do with income so not all
homeschooling parents qualify for this
EFA fund they're I believe it's a cap of
$75,000 per year you can correct me if
I'm wrong but each student is awarded
approximately
$5,000 per year that's roughly
25% of what the average cost of funding
a pupil in the school system is and
so what your bill is proposing is that
homeschooling students meet the same
standards or prove that they are capable
of reading and writing according
to their
peers and so my
suggestion for all of you is that if you
want these homeschooling students to
meet the same standards as publicly
educated students then I would strongly
suggest increasing the amount of money
that these homeschooling parents are
receiving to match the same level of
Education that you're giving or the same
cost that you're giving these publicly
funded students I also write um have
written down here that to touch upon on
what you were just discussing with the
person before me is that college
colleges and
um some of the top tier higher education
institutions like Harvard are actually
moving away from accepting standardized
testing including the SAT and the act
and so what we're seeing is public
outcry from
Educators from all different levels not
just Elementary Middle High School but
College as well that standardized
testing is actually
becoming kind of useless your your time
is up perfect thank you so much thank
you very much for
oer Stephen
Allen
and Kathy Baker looks like that Parker
hello hi my name's Lydia oi I am a
homeschool mother of four uh I hold a
degree in sociology and am currently in
law school right now as well my oldest
two have already graduated high school
one is uh continuing her education at
Boston architectural College my other is
heading out to Africa to do humanitarian
work I have two more in homeschool high
school right now and uh they're finding
out who they are and what they want to
be and it's it's an exciting process um
and I'm in school too and so it's this
journey that we see in homeschooling
that education never ends learning that
was the goal when my husband and I went
into uh homeschooling was we wanted our
kids to love learning and see it as a
forever thing it's exciting to learn
what people shared today there's so many
of the points that I agree with
thoroughly there's one thing that I want
to point to just in particular for you
all um and it was touched on by somebody
much earlier they they pointed out um um
the the case law between Pierce and
versus the Society of sisters that um
was determined by the Supreme Court back
in 1925 and I want she read one sentence
from it I want to read the paragraph
because I think it encompasses much that
pertains to what is being discussed
today um under the doctrine of Meer
versus Nebraska this was a the opinion
given by Justice MC Reynolds under the
doctrine of Meyer versus Nebraska we
think it entirely PL
that the act of 1922 unreasonably
interferes with the liberty of parents
and Guardians to direct the upbringing
and education of children under their
control as often here to pointed out
rights guaranteed by the Constitution
may not be Abridged by legislation which
has no reasonable relation to some
purpose within the competency competency
of the state the fundamental theory of
Liberty upon which all governments in
this Union Repose excludes any G general
power of the state to standardize its
children by forcing them to accept
instruction from public teachers only
the child is not the mere creature of
the state those who nurture him and
direct his Destiny have the right
coupled with a high duty to recognize
and prepare him for additional
obligations that being coupled with the
information that the standardized test
has not been effective it is not being
effective it is being thrown out in many
places it does not appear to be a
reasonable form of standardization for
the competent of children in our state
and I think that we would find some
legal issues if we were to pursue with
it thank you very much thank you are
there questions from the
committee thank you thank you so much
yep stepen
Allen um Kathy
Hawkins
there no yeah
yeah Stephen Allen a resident of lman
New Hampshire a father of two
homeschooled non-fa
193a
students the last two speakers kind of
stole a little bit of my thunder uh but
uh I want
to relate to you I have multiple college
degrees for two decades I've worked in a
learning and education environment uh
some as an educator but for the last
nine supporting graduate level education
at a global top 30 University public top
five University and during that time I
have witnessed the
devaluing of standardized assessments
for college admittance and use both
undergraduate and for gradu even the
specific exams like the lsats and the
mcats and stuff like that they've been
devaluing those
also uh I want I relate that to you to
demonstrate my passion and understanding
the value of Education now I do choose
for our own homeschool assessments to do
standardized testing for specific couple
reasons I can pick the test to best fit
our uh curriculum second I can make that
test as less or as distressful as
possible for my
children with placing them in a highly
stressed environment when they haven't
been in a public school where the days
are chosen does not allow them the best
situation for me to assess where they
might have weaknesses so that I can
alter the curriculum the following year
and while I do not accept EFA money and
will not my opinion here and that
benefit that I get a choosey assessment
when I can uh give it would apply EFA
parents as well they can make sure that
the assessment they provide is done in a
way that gets the most useful assessment
information to the parent it's not going
to be of any use to the public schools
they're not the Educators we are for our
children thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the
committee thank
you Kathy uh
Baker yes hello I'm Kathy Baker I'm a
homeschool mom
um one of the things that um is very
clear to me is that um we already have
under our current
rsas accountability through various
means of evaluation for all four classes
of students in our states both types of
homeschoolers private schools and public
including public charter schools and so
I wonder because I know that the
sponsors of this bill know that this is
not news to them so I wonder why they
put forth this bill they put forth today
and I can only assume that the purpose
of this bill is to destroy diversity and
educational choice you have already
heard from many parents talking about
the issues of teaching to the test and
that homeschoolers and not mentioned but
private schools and Charter Schools all
offer their own curriculums which are
not necessarily the same as public
school um
and if you are forcing all of these
institutions and every student in the
state to be evaluated on the public
school curriculum You Are by virtue
destroying diversity in curriculums and
tailoring of curriculums to individual
children and I'm thinking perhaps
there's a threat felt by the moneyed
interests in the schools um for example
um as our state education commissioner
mentioned that we now have 32 public
charter schools in the state each of
them serving a different mission for
more than 5,500 students
Statewide um instructing based on
students unique needs this enhances
education for the individual students
across the state and this is what our
state education committee here as well
as all our state reps and people in the
state should want but the moneyed
interests probably don't like that there
are 55,000 people in public Charters
which are under a different umbrella
they probably don't like and in fact I
believe there's been a direct attack in
this bill on the EFA program I don't
participate in the EFA program but they
are already evaluated they already have
an RSA that has a structure for
supervision and accountability and again
the sponsors of this bill know that but
gosh if we start providing people money
to choose this private school or this
charter school or extra help for
homeschooling when you know we might
have a working that needs to be home
people feel threatened and that's what
this bill is an attack on and I ask you
to um ditch it with your inexpedient to
thank you very much any questions from
the committee oh I'm
thank you uh Carolyn
Mayer good afternoon thank you house
chairman and members of the education
committee uh my name is Carolyn Hawkins
I'm from Milford New Hampshire and uh I
was public educated and I went to
Virginia Tech for my bachelor's in
horiculture and and I'm familiar with
standardized testing it was not my
favorite growing up but I had to learn
to master that um I am a wife of 26
years to a veteran and a mother of four
children two of whom have graduated from
our homeschooling of 17 years um we
began homeschooling in Pensacola Florida
so Florida law was our first
introduction we were required annual
testing we had a a homeschool umbrella
Co-op that we did the Iowa Test which
covered a lot more than just reading
math and language um so having that
first picture of it um we moved to New
Hampshire was 10 years ago now so I was
thankful for the freedoms that we had um
to choose is an assessment better
evaluation I've kept portfolios I have
so many portable containers of my
schools My Children's School uh work um
my two that have graduated high High
School dual enrolled at Nashville
Community College um I had to keep a
transcript for them and then when they
graduated from the state as you all know
we have to make sure that they have
completed the required um education and
all of the different things so I am
unfunded um traditional I guess we've
lived on a shoestring budget for many
years under one income um but our goal
was not to teach our children for
testing understand the value of of some
of those testings it's helped me when my
children have needed more time in some
of the subjects so I have a full
um I think the one thing with the um EAS
is there's already things in place so
when I heard about this just this
morning I I drove up from Milford and I
said you know we we have freedoms we
have laws in place and I think we should
oppose this House Bill 1610 because we
already have laws that regulate what
we're required as homeschool parents to
do and I think for this next Generation
coming to have that freedom especially
with all the testimony today for those
who have special need children or you
know our children need to get outside
there's so much learning outside your
time is up now thank you so much I
appreciate it Virginia Tech has a good
basketball team this year too yes they
do yes they do go
re good afternoon good afternoon my name
is Nicole Lee and I live in Broadford
New Hampshire we are an unfunded
traditional homeschooling family and I
oppose house bills 1610 we actually
don't meet the requirements to get
funding otherwise we would because we
are always over budget with our
homeschooling um and we did try public
schooling in the year 2021 2022 my
oldest attended a public preschool um
and we did decide to withdraw him from
the kindergarten registration because
many different circumstances that arise
during the year including bullying
anxiety and just overall negative
behavioral changes that we saw within
him um we opposed the bill for all of
the same reasons we've seen come up here
so I won't go through everything but I
will say that I was publicly educated in
the State of Florida and um I was never
a great test taker it
actually did not enhance anything that I
had ever learned and honestly I
literally studied to pass a test and not
to actually learn and as I have been
teaching my own children I'm actually
more excited now to learn the subjects
that I kind of didn't we just skimmed
through them so that I could pass a test
um so that really sticks out in my mind
that I already know how my kids tests
take and it's not great because we do
assess them ourselves um so I am asking
you to please oppose House Bill 1610 and
add this to the testimonies today thank
you questions are from the
committee thank you very much uh Sarah
Sarah
good afternoon I am Sarah may I live in
Anum New Hampshire this is my son Ron
who is with me in solidarity opposing
this bill he does not have a prepared
statement uh I'm the mother of six
children two of them are EFA students we
had to terminate our home education
program in order to enroll them in the
fa which we use to send them to a a
private school in our town that was the
best choice that we made as parents for
the education of our two high schoolers
it has worked out wonderfully now I
understand that some standardized
testing is part and parcel of accepting
State funds I think it's foolish but it
is what it is and they are already
participating in some standardized
testing that is being reported I got the
test scores um after they participated
in those tests at the school I have in
the past used the California achievement
test as my endof year evaluation for my
other four homeschooled students which
are traditional and unfunded and I have
seen both uh the demoralizing effects on
my children who look at test questions
and burst into tears because they don't
know how to answer them I think and also
I have
seen how any kind of time enforcement on
those tests is just not helpful I
have uh mostly used portfolio
evaluations for our home education
program and has turned out so much
better um this is a deviation from my
written prepared statement as all of the
other reasons why I oppose this bill
have been addressed but I did want to
mention that no standardized testing is
going to to reflect the learning that my
children have today in coming coming to
this
hearing they also do not reflect the
amount of time that we put into in our
home education program to teach them
courtesy responsibility perseverance
Grace kindness patience respect for
authority and
self-control and the Golden Rule these
things are not going to be reflected on
whether they know that helium is a noble
gas or that 137 is a prime number by any
particular age I oppose this bill please
vote in expedient to legislate thank you
thank you for taking the time today to
come down um any questions from the
committee thank you very much thank
you and
Marie then uh Kim
pixler um good afternoon members of the
committee thank you for taking my
testimony um my name is Amar Banfield
I'm a parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire focused on education uh I do
support in terms of the transparency
that you are seeking I think that that's
important and I and I would support
something like that I cannot support uh
the bill as written I cannot support for
standardized testing of the state
standardized test on EFA students on
homeschool students on students in
private schools on anybody including
students in public schools this test is
seriously flawed I'm happy to expand on
that if I run out of time feel free to
ask me um but we have a seriously
followed test to begin with so forcing
this on any child any
school um I think is is is
counterproductive
um first of all the time that is that
you would have to invest because they're
already required to take the test so a
private school is going to already give
them their test that they that they
choose so now you're going to add many
many hours of a student having to take
another test that's a big
problem
um fair test.org is a great source uh
representative lad you looking for um uh
schools colleges that don't take the SAT
fair test.org I think it's was up to 800
colleges in universities don't even look
at the SAT I know that um St anoms does
not um I cannot support the amendment
again because even though it might pull
some of these students out it doesn't
pull them all out and if my child were
in a public school I would refuse this
test but I as I have recommended to
other public school students because it
is so flawed and then I would I I
normally uh recommend that they take
another maybe like a classical
achievement test which is quite
different um I don't know if you knew
this but when No Child Left Behind was
uh Sunset it and then we U moved to Essa
Essa also included in change the
accountability so accountability was not
just your standardized test it is now
also uh grading skills so I can go to
the standards and I can read the
standards that'll be tested but I don't
see anything public on skills so asking
these schools to administer a test that
they don't even know what skills are
going to be
tested doesn't set you up for Success
your time is up okay yeah yeah I think
that our kids are set up for failure
taking this test in any school
environment thank you are there any
questions from the
committee not see any thank you very
molan
um Amber Amber
fixler
Amber and next one miss
shayen
Moran I guess good afternoon my name is
Amber fixler I'm a constituent from
Epsom New Hampshire we have been
homeschooling our three children for the
entirety of their education we are
traditional unfunded homeschooling
family I've already sent my testimony
through email to all of you I stand in
opposition to HB 1610 because of the
need to test all students in the state
including home education students
according to the language of the
bill um one of the reasons that I oppose
this is that home educated students like
ourselves are already required to
complete an annual evaluation which we
happily do um I recognize the state may
need to evaluate its public education
system
through portfolios or evaluations or
standardized testing um and even to
provide documentation of EFA students
progress however um the data collected
on home educated students in that
category isn't going to have any um any
meaning for someone analyzing that
data another reason I oppose this bill
is that it is increasing regulatory
requirements on homeschooling families
and students in general um people are
able to find folks with similar values
um and I can attest that the local
in-person homeschooling networks and
online homeschooling networks that are
nationwide are U robust and I see that a
lot of homeschooling families wishing to
relocate consider New Hampshire for many
really great reasons my husband and I
are both longtime lifelong residents of
New Hampshire um he's a veteran of a
local National Guard unit we both have
Bachelor degrees from New Hampshire
colleges so we love New Hampshire
however um it's considered moderate for
its homeschooling regulations only New
York Connecticut Pennsylvania and
Massachusetts are more highly regulated
than New Hampshire for homeschooling
laws um I don't want to see New
Hampshire become the most strictly
regulated state for homeschooling in New
Hampshire um another reason that I
oppose this bill is that it allows for
public schooling families to exempt
their students from this testing however
that same exemption privilege is not
given to other types of
students um it is my personal belief
that New Hampshire overall will benefit
from encouraging families to live and
work here by improving the schools by
decreasing regulations that apply to
homeschoolers and students in general in
our great lier die State increasing
educational freedom and maybe even
increasing homeschooling family numbers
in New Hampshire is going to benefit our
local communities your time is up and
our state thank you thank you very much
any questions from the committee not see
Moran then uh Jody
what's
this
no
well I don't
know well Zer blower didn't do a good
job here
um William
McKenzie go ahead thank you for the
opportunity to speak I am an independent
homeschooling mother from wolfboro New
Hampshire um much of much of my personal
testimony has been touched on already
but but just a couple of things that I
would like to say is that ideally an
assessment's purpose is to act as a tool
for educators to show their students
growth proficiency and reveal areas in
which a student may need more support
the reality is that in public schools
EST State assessments are also an
accountability measure to ensure
taxpayer dollars are being used
effectively toward the educational
growth of the children whose families
have chosen to enroll their kids in that
educational path the state the T state
test designed for the educational
approach chose for use in public schools
would never be able to act as an
accurate measure for children across a
very broad academic landscape including
privately schooled independently
homeschooled or those along one of the
variety of paths afforded uh to families
who use education Freedom accounts to
fund their child's education uh finally
in our school district despite a 90%
graduation rate and according to the
state standardized test scores only 36%
of high school students test scores
reveal Prof efficiency in math and 50%
of middle schoolers test scores
reflected a proficient reading level as
a taxpayer and a parent who cares very
much about the education of the children
in our state I would much rather see the
budget recommended for this bill around
2.5 million annual public tax dollars go
toward improving academic rigor within
the public school system in order to do
what is best by the families who have
enrolled their children in that
educational path thank you very much
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
thank
Jody you said me uh y y thank you are
am
afternoon someone said earlier I don't
want to be here I was kind of laughing
we can all agree on
that uh my name is Kim moltisanti I
homeschool four children children in
marac New Hampshire we are an unfunded
uh RSA
193a homeschool family I oppose this
bill as um almost everyone here does so
many points were made today that I
completely scrapped my notes and I'm
going to read this chicken scratch here
I'd like to just address um the these
this bill is was written with very broad
language and so everyone's talking about
amendments and all these things and
that's the the part that the people of
New Hampshire where we get nervous
because we came here for our freedom
when I met my husband I lived in
Massachusetts and he lived in New
Hampshire and he works in nsha and I was
pushing to live closer to my family and
he said it's going to be more free in
New Hampshire the home school laws are
Freer the life is Freer and now I'm
looking at this if this bill passes it
will be the strictest and most regulated
homeschool state in the United States
which is wild to me so I'm asking you to
oppose it um and and one more point
there there are a lot of families here
that are accept accepting the EA fund
for lots of reasons uh right wrong or
indifferent I want you to consider the
number of families here who qualify for
the help and don't ask for it it's
because we want to be left alone I'm not
asking you my tax dollars go to your
schools I'm that's great I'm not asking
for funding to homeschool my kids we're
taking on that financial burden and
sacrifice just to be left alone and I
think that's that's probably the biggest
point I could make today so thank you
for listening do you have any questions
thank you questions for the
committee thank you thank you very
much
um going to jump uh to lra
Lara
hello
welcome my name is lar Brown and I live
in bosow New Hampshire I'm opposing this
bill because it would make me and my
brother and sister go into a public
school and take a test every year the
reason I do not want to do this is
because public school kids do not have
to take this test so why should
we thank you for your time thank you
very much Lara L you're 10 years old yes
conquered the golden
Castle don't worry that isn't going to
happen you um I'll just leave it at that
talking
okay
um see we got here uh Jody
pereria good
afternoon I'm still
around
yeah New Hampshire by degree is not
displaying the level of ignorance we've
seen in our neighbors in Maine or
Colorado which was uh on the front page
news now the Supreme Court has shown
them their level of ignorance they
cannot
unilaterally an individual in Maine or a
group of whoever in Colorado deny all
other citizens in their state the right
to
vote how stupid Have We
Become in gown are you speaking to the
bill which
ising I oppose schooling and the FAS and
that and the assessments I I oppose the
bill 1610
10 uh because they don't have the right
they have not earned the right to have
jurisdiction over those who uh
sacrifice you know so much to give their
children the best
that they
can U as I was going to say the history
teacher of the year happens to be in
gtown I spoke to him and asked him when
do your classes start what period in
history the Civil War the whole founding
of our nation is blotted out by a public
school
system did you no wonder the children
are
confused um literacy in
America
preceded formal
education and it was a high rate of
literacy I'm talking in the high 90th
percentile Connecticut uh
Massachusetts uh New Hampshire if you
look at the
1853 New Hampshire school board report
and look at the charts uh I think in the
whole town of uh gtown there might have
only been a couple children or even
adults were counted that could not read
and write your your time is up okay
thank thank you very much if you have
written comment uh could you please give
it to represent belshire over there and
we'll have it put in the record yes and
I blotted out the name of the rep
representative that's in one of the you
know pieces of
information and the reason is
because uh of potential intimidation or
whatever like education of parities
against an
individual thank thank you very
much the next person to be called
yes good afternoon um my name is Serena
vley and I reside in Conquer New
Hampshire I have seven kids and over the
years I've homeschooled them I've
private school sent them to private
school public school we've done vac
we've
done um online school and we've
done the EFA program so a lot of the
things here have already been covered so
I don't want to focus on that today um
and I agree with almost all of it but
what I wanted to talk about today was um
the education Freedom account so if the
bill is focused just on stuent
recipients of the education Freedom
account I'd like to just
um point out that the purpose of the
education Freedom account was
Freedom
meaning it covers people sending kids or
having kids homeschool sending kids to
private school and the idea was wanting
to encourage homeschooling and other
things so I understand it's a separate
program but the purpose was to encourage
Freedom um so the testing that we have
makes sense
in the context of public schools so we
are the state is over public schools and
so therefore would need to test them
because we have authority over those and
we need to make sure like we're
administering them so we need to see how
they're working and use that testing to
evaluate and that's the purpose of
testing and that's fine but in this
context of um the people who are doing
homeschooling and other things um the
idea was to give people that freedom and
not to impose more regulation and I just
one thing that I want to point out is
that we don't have control over private
schools or um homeschooling families we
you have control over the schools the
public schools so that the testing is
only for that and as other people have
said we already have requirements that
we have to meet um and then I would just
finally say that you're here to serve
the New Hampshire people and there
aren't the New Hampshire people are not
asking for this they're not there's
nobody saying this is what we need so I
just ask that you vote in expedient to
legislate thank you any questions from
the
Pereira uh Dove
Gregorian
uh is Jody
a consoles here
tried pardon
me Jody
yeah you don't get the
card I'm there somewhere
good afternoon everybody it's a long day
isn't it uh my name is jod Underwood I
live in cro New Hampshire um my husband
and I coote this testimony a lot of
which I am not going to read because
it's been covered um but I will share my
the testimony with um representative
beler after um so I have to say that
this bill appears to be a thinly
disguised attempt to subject
home-educated students to the kind of
micro and mismanagement that prompted
their parents to keep them out of
schools in the first place
now this interpretation can't be
dismissed out of hand my husband
personally witnessed members of an
activist Group which includes one of the
Bill's sponsors formulating plans to
collect copies of the birth certificates
of all the children born in New
Hampshire in order to keep tabs on
children whose parents keep them out of
the system excuse
me I'm
person that's not a factual statement it
was his experience he was there he saw
it
I will will you state on task with this
bill please well it is it was completely
about the
bill so that was point one um we do
agree that if a student is taking money
from taxpayers those taxpayers have an
interest in seeing what they're getting
something that they're getting something
for their money we might call this the
if we pay we get a say principle or pay
say for short so this would also mean
that it would appli to public schools so
and right now public school students can
exempt themselves from taking the state
assessment but that goes against the
accountability that this test is
supposed to do so if you know in other
words if you don't want your kids to
take those assessments that's fine but
then they shouldn't be able to attend
the schools right for free they would
have to make other arrangements like
paid tuition or homeschool or otherwise
um my third Point um adds on to what
representative seller said he mentioned
learning environments and that there was
a problem with such a broad statement
and I just wanted to add on to that to
to um give further examples so it it's a
very vague statement so for example if I
use EFA funds to pay for jiujitsu
classes piano lessons and these are used
for these um types of classes that
clearly takes place in a learning
environment if I use EA funds to buy a
computer so my kid my kid can use Con
Academy that's clearly a learning
environment does that mean that the gym
or the time is up that was 2 minutes
that was two minutes wow damn oh well
all right um thank you you're more than
welcome uh Jen
Perera do adove adov
Gregorian
me okay like Dove it looks like an O but
that's fine we'll go with the
a
Dave are you Dave yes sir okay okay go
ahead hello my name is Jennifer Pereira
I'm from Manchester New Hampshire I'm
the president of Catholics United for
home education a Statewide home school
organization we did already email you a
statement in opposition to this bill
what I would like to share is my
personal testimony um I have brought
with me today an essay which my
16-year-old son wrote um it is about
Hannibal's March um and his first major
victory in Italy he went back to primary
sources and he read them and he
formulated this Essay with good par
structure sentences which would be good
for any child um but I'm especially
proud of him because he could not have
taken a standardized test in early
elementary school because he has
dyslexia he could not read or write well
in those years um so I am bringing this
essay for you to look at as a positive
outcome for homeschooling thank you
thank you very much now do we have a
copy of that or are you going to drop
that off thank you
yes uh Dave
Gregorian sorry for uh bittering your
name no
reason Kate Kate Bloom will be next and
Lambert welcome good afternoon uh Dave
gin here um we're a traditional unfunded
uh 193a homeschool family of two uh
we're here to oppose hb610
the reason is fundamentally the purpose
of this bill really is to function as a
poison pill for the entire homeschooling
Community it is intended to push us all
of us whether traditional 193 or EFA
families teach each to uh a very
problematic test that is linked to a
mediocre and morally bankrupt Common
Core
Curriculum as such it's really an it's
it's an attack on homeschooling families
and families in general because it is
presupposes that
um the government
um School
administrators ass sorted other other
bureaucrats know it is best for our kids
better than we do as
parents we should be the primary
decision makers not the state not the
education system those of us who choose
to participate in the
homeschooling uh
Endeavor in
and if you think about it logically why
did we go through all this difficulty
all this trouble of embarking on this
homeschool project because we want to
avoid these tests these government tests
we want to avoid Common Core we want to
avoid everything that comes all that
negative baggage that we associate with
the public education system that's
precisely what we work so hard to avoid
and what this bill is doing is
essentially fostering it back back upon
us um so for that reason um we would
like to we you know we strongly oppose
this bill and we'd like to uh see it
rejected in its entirety without
amendments just completely rejected in
full you know basically K like the
Supreme Court said in 1925 the kids
belong to the to the parents to the moms
and dads not to the state um and that's
what we that's what we are here to
defend thank you thank you very
much any questions the
committee okay Kate
Bloom
y done hi I'm Kate Bloom from where New
Hampshire a lot of my topics have been
touched on so I'm going to come at this
from a different angle as a taxpayer um
in the state of New Hampshire I am also
a traditional unschooling or traditional
homeschooling family with three children
um so the fiscal note on this bill says
that it will cost the state at least 2.5
$5 million a year um plus the cost in
the local education if the goal is to be
accountable to the taxpayers does it
really Mak sense to be spending $2.5
million a year to force unfunded
homeschoolers and EFA students to take
assessments when we already have
accountability measures in place via
required annual education assessments
this is something that is already
covered under current law do we need to
spend Millions more dollars every year
of taxpayer money I don't think so um
few questions to ponder on do the
results of standardized tests prove the
Worth or adequacy of an education will
these test results be used to determine
if the EFA program is successful or if
the tax money is being spent in a
worthwhile way if you do think the
results of a test can prove that money
isn't being spent well then what does
that say about the public school system
and its accountability to taxpayers we
only need to look at the alarmingly low
State assessment data of public school
students to show that public schools are
fa in and their obligation to taxpayers
yet there's no recourse for misuse of
public funds for public school
students under New Hampshire homeschool
law annual educational assessments are
private and can't be used to terminate a
home education program with these
required State assessments the results
will be reported to the state does being
forced to take State assessments open us
up to some kind of scrutiny if our child
doesn't meet a certain level this is a
direct conflict with the statutes that
have been secured via the home school
law that is already in place um please
vote against hb1 1610 thank you thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you very much
uh Trisha
denes I'm gonna bring my son with me is
fine thank you Mr chair and members of
the education committee my name is
Lambert and I am a mother of a
homeschooler um who is sitting next to
me um his name is Reed um who uh is
under
193a um which is unfunded so I guess the
first thing I want to talk about is um
well I'll get back to the unfunded piece
um just a quick story um everybody has
said things um many different ways and
and they're all true
um I still follow our school board I
still go to their meeting despite that I
I homeschool um and because I care I
care where my money goes as a taxpayer
and I also care and what they're
receiving um I recently um about a year
ago I went to our budget committee which
sets the budget and um a conversation
ensued this became very clear to me when
I read this language of this bill it
seems awful familiar to me is that there
was a long discussion about tracking of
home education
students and and as it relates to money
it relates to money so this was very
disturbing to me um and I told them so
that we don't track children number one
number two they're they don't have a
dollar sign on their head and so when I
read this despite the fact we're
spending $2.5 million
to um effectively make this both so um
it really is trying to do exactly that
it's trying to check
children um I I don't want to um I don't
need to use my full two minutes but
going back to the unfunded what this is
about is
contracts we do not have a contract with
the state we do not have a contract with
the local
municipality we pulled them out and we
did that for a reason to provide our own
education so I'm not quite sure in
trying to and I realize there's an
amendment to change things around I'm
not quite sure how legal this would be
we do not have a contract so I will
leave it there and I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you very much other
questions from the
Kristen Krist I appreciate this my uh
parking meter is about to run out how
many times does run out uh no I have
parked in three hours so I still have
about 10 minutes Joseph perelli is next
my name is Kristen dennisk I live in
hener I'm speaking as an RSA 193a
independent unfunded homeschool parent I
just want to thank the committee first
of all for remaining to listen to so
many testimonies I've been to hearings
before where they didn't sit and listen
and it was infuriating I submitted my
testimony through the online portal
everything I wanted to say has been said
and said clearly I think so I won't
repeat it I think we could have a
hearing about this proposed amendment
because I don't trust it to be written
well I ask that you either ensure an
amendment approved by Michelle LEL
passes or vote itl against this bill
outright I also ask as politely as
possible that in the future you please
don't forget to exclude us RSA 193a
independent unfunded homeschool families
perelli
NOP uh
Erica uh
G what
is
gter
here
and are you are you Joseph yes can you
just wait until after this one right
here
that okay with you
you hello for the record my name is
Erica Golder I'm from lonia New
Hampshire I am an unfunded homeschooling
parent I appreciate the opportunity to
express my concerns here with hb610
I urge you to oppose this bill uh itl
um I just want to say that the state has
absolutely no right to intervene into a
parent choice for their children which
is statistically far superior to your
institutional model um that's exactly
what this bill will
do I can hand this in but I have um
plenty of homeschooling statistics uh
just in lonia for instance when we're
talking about the public institutional
School the uh we have five schools
there's 1831 students we have 178
teachers for a public school the the
graduation rate is um 80 to 84% on
average math proficiency is
24% reading proficiency is
31% uh they spend over $20,000 per
education um just a a few homeschooling
statistics uh 15 to 25% above
um homeschoolers
homeschooling tests uh I'm sorry let me
start over 15 to 25% homeschoolers test
above public school students on
standardized tests I know you heard
somebody uh previously saying that they
didn't make enough money to um uh give
their child a good enough education to
do well on this test but frankly the
students aren't taught the the
curriculum to do well in these tests um
just shouldn't exist
um the degree of State control and
regulation of homeschooling is not
related to academic achievement that was
per US Department of Education uh that
was their statement in
2019 again I'm going to be submitting
this information here um just have three
quick questions I have other statistics
that you can read
later uh question number one how is
inserting institutional school policies
into the homeschooling curriculum going
to help or improve anything where the
institutional model is statistically
inferior number two why do we not take a
a better look at the homeschool model
which is statistically Superior and why
and uh was which is statistically
Superior and not Implement intrusive
State policies into the homeschool model
and the third and final rhetorical
question is how is it that the state how
is it that the average cost per
homeschooled student is
11% what the national public school
child is yet homeschooled children and
most metrics are academically double
digits ahead of the institutional
counterparts thank thank you very much
questions questions from the
Joseph and then Steven
Ramsey good afternoon thank you for your
time my name is Joseph pelli um
represent my 193a homeschool family live
in Dober um obviously I like everyone
else here I show up today to speak
against this poorly written bill um
rather than reiterating what's already
been said I'd like to focus on two
points uh this bill does nothing to help
students and families in the state
however according to the bill analysis
and as many of others have said it's
going to cost $2.5 million per fiscal
year $2 million loan
um just for the tracking uh portion of
it data collection on the students that
will be taking the
test again this provides absolutely no
benefit to anyone while it carries a
tremendous cost to
taxpayers point two it is disingenuous
and perhaps deceitful for representative
cascaden to Pedal this as a bill that's
EFA related uh this bill is written as
in as it is written requires
standardized testing of all students
from all uh public non-public and all
learning environments unfortunately she
forgot to update the part where public
school students were allowed
to just talk reference the bill sure uh
it was poorly written and doesn't allow
uh anyone but the public school students
to uh opt
out uh we need to be able to trust our
representatives and these kind of
deceptive tactics to insert the state
into lives of families only serve to
erode that trust uh so if any future
bills come up again like this I ask to
please not waste our time and expect
that we will show up again in opposition
to that bill as we care about our
children and we like to ra healthy happy
children who are well educated according
to the way that we wish to educate our
children and doesn't require any
standardized testing to do
so thank you very much other questions
from the committee thank you
uh in the back of the room are you have
a young child on your lap are you
waiting to speak I already did yeah I
thought
so uh Steve okay Steve
yes and then
Lisa
neston great good afternoon and thank
you for allowing me to speak um my name
is step and I live in DOA New Hampshire
and we homeschool our kids and I POS
this bill that would require mandatory
standardized test in all learning
environments including homeschooling we
do not participate in the fa program but
I'm going to Echo a concern because I
think it's important to reiterate that
you know the language in The Spill as
it's written it does not clearly
distinguish the difference between
families that receive EFA funds and
families that don't I'm also very
concerned about standardized test in
general because there's a lot of
concerns and valid criticism and as a
father I share the same ones some of
them include they don't capture all the
students skills and achievements
standardized test scores don't predict
future success there can be a lot of
pressure to perform well which leads to
teaching the test test questions could
be biased and standard tests may only
determine which students are good at
taking tests and not you know their
actual knowledge of a subject it's like
a snapshot in time you know if I can use
an analogy you know even a professional
All-Star athletes they have bad days you
know we don't just judge an athletes
ability based on one game because one
game doesn't reflect the entire season
nor does a a standardized test capture
what's going on in the learning
environment and these shortfalls are
even more concerning when trying to
apply a standardized test to all
learning environments you know we're so
lucky to live in New Hampshire because
we have different learning options for
our kids we have public schools private
schools charter schools and
homeschooling which we do and these
learning environments all have their own
distinct teaching methods and they all
have their own unique advantages and
this is great because parents can choose
the options that's best for their kids
now every child is different so it
doesn't make sense to expect every child
to Excel and exceed in every type of
learning environment it also doesn't
make sense to test their performance the
same way across all learning
environments so I please uh oppose this
bill that set forth today thank you
thank you very much other questions from
the
committee thank you very much Lisa
neston and then uh
Wendy
Carson
Clawson
okay hi good afternoon my name is Lis
Lucen and I live in do New Hampshire
with my husband and our two young
daughters we are a traditional
homeschool family we are not part of the
EFA program and I'm strongly opposed to
this bill before homeschooling our
children I was an elementary school
teacher for 15 years one of the first
things I learned as a teacher was that a
formative assessment one which giv
information to help improve student
learning is not an end of the unit test
or quiz or for our purposes today a
standardized
test formative assessments give
immediate and ongoing feedback about
what a child has learned and they are
tools to be used as an educator to guide
instruction so I actually created
portfolios for each child year after
year I found that these portfolios
clearly showed students progress to
their parents while standardized test
scores only provide a snapshot of a
student's performance on one particular
day as homeschooling families we are
already conducting formative assessments
we constantly observe and assess our
children on a day-to-day basis without
for standardized assessments and we are
making adjustments to meet the
individual individual needs of our own
children for my own family I have no
doubt that a standardized assessment
would do more harm than good I have one
child who has severe test anxiety
especially when tasks are timed if she
were forced to take these timed
standardized assessments while sitting
in a strange classro filled with
unfamiliar children and adults I highly
doubt that we be provided with any
objective
data and while this proposal allows
Public School parents to exempt their
children from this assessment there is
nothing which allows non-public school
parents to exempt their children as
well finally I would like to remind the
Comm
that homeschoolers can already choose
which year in assessment is the best fit
for their family whether it be a
standardized test or an annual portfolio
review do not remove these assessment
options from families please vote
inexpedient to legislate thank you thank
you very much are there any questions
from the committee thank you all right
may I pass this into somebody yes yes
right over to represent beler Wendy
hello uh Wendy Clawson I live in Ashland
uh I currently homeschool my son um I
don't do that as a choice I do it
because uh he has a rare genetic
disorder and public school does not work
for him tests do not work for him and he
is just a little bit different than
everyone we knew he was different as
soon as he was like 3 years old on the
soccer field um but he doesn't fit into
any bucket of specific diagnosis um it
took us 3 years of testing to find out
what was wrong with him I always say
what was wrong with him because he has
many gifts because of this
um we have money we moved here from New
York because we knew that New York
schools would fail my son um we came up
here and we said New Hampshire because
we like the Live Free or Die attitude we
love the Clean Air and um outdoors and
you know the ruggedness that comes in
the school we love our school district
we live in Ashland they did everything
they could for my son and when he was in
first grade it was great but when he
entered second grade things went
downhill really fast I don't know what
happened to my son but he basically had
a complete nervous breakdown he was in
and out of doctor's offices for about a
year he couldn't leave the house he was
freaking out well six months and then
summer came and he was fine he was fine
like the whole summer back to himself we
didn't think it was school cuz school
was something that he actually enjoyed
but he also didn't enjoy it um because
he just can't sit still in a room or
take tests um or listen or do a lot of
other things that actually make him a
really big pain in the butt to be home
all the time so I just want to say it
cost me $100 to be here today to speak
about this because he's not in school
every single day I have to be with my
son this cost me a lot it cost me my
heart it cost me my time they cost time
with my other
children I love my son I do it because
it's right for him I have the money to
do it
I can spend the $100 to be here but you
know who can the educational Freedom
families who probably also have children
like my son and so while a lot of people
have been speaking here about
homeschooling today and not receiving
funds so we shouldn't be tested I don't
think anyone should be if you're
homeschooling your kid that's 10 weeks
for that $5,000 10 weeks you would have
a babysitting Public Schools why it's
much easier it is much easier to do
Public School your time is up oh thank
you um
thank thank you very much for coming and
you have a wonderful Dunkin' Donuts up
in Ashlin where they welcome we have the
best dunk you have the best that's right
do I go to another Dunkin' Donuts I'm
Valley okay Richard
Khan I wasn't sure I was going to be
able to make it cuz uh I'm about at the
three-hour limit of my
meter uh Richard KH Hudson New Hampshire
I have a bachelor's degree in computer
systems engineering I have a master's
degree in
education I've substitute taught K
through 12 I've tutored privately math
mostly
science sat
GED I am a father a
grandfather I run a landscaping business
have been for the last 23 years I've run
for office at the federal state and
local level
and largely because of where my family
comes from other
countries I don't trust the government
to do pretty much
anything I only put down for one minute
of speaking time but I have all kinds of
anecdotal evidence if uh there's any
room for it so I oppose this bill and
I'll take any questions are there any
questions from the
committee none thank you very much
Emily
Elliott is Rihanna Valley
here Emily
Wendell good afternoon uh my name is Dan
wandell I'm from we New Hampshire this
is my son August
um August is a uh one of four
homeschooled children we are um
independent unfunded um but frankly you
know based on the testimony today as
well as um you know sort of being in the
homeschool experience and Adventure um
the uh imposition
of of standardized testing or regulatory
framework on top of homeschooling in
general is something we vly opposeed
whether um those tests are assessed onto
independent home schoolers who do not
receive funds um or folks who are
taxpayers themselves who are essentially
um you know using their own money to um
educate their children uh as as they see
fit in the EFA program um I I would not
distinguish the um the imposition of
testing on anyone um to be uh something
that would produce better outcomes
something that would um you know
properly uh assess uh students ability
to sort of learn um or um make progress
throughout their lives um as has been
echoed um we are um you know transplants
we we come from um from Massachusetts we
specifically sought out New Hampshire um
because of its um you know its
friendliness towards Liberty um its um
instincts towards um you know the
sovereignty of individuals to um uh you
know have sovereignty over their own
lives and particularly the lives of
their children um what standardization
and what regulation does is is you know
diminishes you know the the free spirit
and ability to to pursue your own your
own destiny um what assessments do is
fundamentally change the relationship
between the state and the individual and
fundamentally change um the relationship
between you know parents and children um
obviously in and in position of of
standardized testing creates a c
curriculum in and of its stealth um you
know I have you know August is a is a
hunter a fisherman he's our sort of
Junior ornithologist he can name more
birds than you know than you think exist
um and that's a direct result of his
mother teaching him in uh in the manner
that we deem appropriate um there is no
standardized test that would capture
that ability um there is no um you know
regulation that would produce a better
outcome from for him or um or his
siblings um I would urge the committee
to listen to the testimony that's been
that's been brought I I don't believe
there is any um opposition um that
exists among the public to um to
striking down this bill in committee um
and again your your time is up great
thank you so much August looks just like
compliment Jennifer York um Emily
Elliott
here hi I'm Michelle doen I'm I'm from P
I've been teaching H school I guess
unfunded um for six years now uh I teach
in a fail tolearn kind of way I don't
really believe in testing I like to
teach
conversationally my son was in school
till third grade and ended up leaving
there
after that kind of testing environment
calling himself stupid and took years
before he built the confidence to um
learn love love learning again uh so now
I've taught over a hundred different
types of learn um topics of learning we
do dexterity based learning and a lot of
kids will come in with the mindset that
they have to pass or fail that if they
don't leave with something in their
hands that they failed and I like to
teach them that that it's inside of you
that we build the skill and that's
enough um but you can even see in their
eyes that they're terrified to do the
thing wrong and so I spend my time on
making that
mindset which is actually kind of
difficult but they're young uh so in
everything I do that's the goal uh so I
don't believe in testing I don't think
that that's the way you gain things and
I don't really think that that's how we
get to know what kids know and I don't
think that's how we build a love for
learning um it's really important that
we remove that teaching to ATT test is
the way that we should do things because
that's not really how we operate in life
that's not how we've operated any other
time in life except for right now
testing to to know what kids know and
since we've ever been people um I think
it's ridiculous the public school is
failing so that's a good way to assess
that to be honest and to do it to kids
overall when many kids just don't
operate in that kind of way um to do it
to them all it seems ridiculous to me so
thank you for sharing your insights and
your understanding yeah thanks uh any
comments from the
committee thank you no thank
you uh Jennifer
York Emily
she uh Joyce
Allen might be getting some people
hallway Kate Shay maybe oh Kate
Shay it looks like
tea okay yes come on up Kate good
afternoon thank you committee thank you
Mr chair Kate Shay from Goffstown y'all
have heard me a number of times I'll try
to keep it really short because people
have covered most of the points you all
know from prior uh discussions we've had
I have four kids three of special needs
um my mother was a public school teacher
for her whole career and in the end she
ended up leaving her career in her
retirement because she just could not
read out of a manual she did not want to
be teaching to tests and I didn't
believe that this was really happening
in New York state till my nie started to
encounter it as well and would be crying
super smart girls be crying over these
tests and so kind of could see what was
coming to New Hampshire but inevitably
it did come and after many years of me
trying to fit my kids into the system uh
I gave up and actually it was one of the
best things I ever did some people might
look at as giving up I love what she
said about um failing to learn that's
what I do for my job day in the day so I
work with software Engineers we fail to
learn which sounds counterproductive to
what we're trying to do but in essence
you know it it goes against the grain
and so it takes a lot of my coaching it
takes a lot of a teacher kind of
attitude to get them to try it and when
we do that's when we have breakthroughs
um so I asked myself what what's
happened at State assessments since I
went to school and I was one of those
circling whatever little bubble there
was and having a good old time not
caring about exactly what it was doing
to my test scores but essentially as we
know they're here to inform future
instruction to evaluate Mastery so I'd
like to ask you today are these things
really providing a litmus test to
Mastery or not so we've talked about you
know there's already a portfolio review
or an option to do a standardized test
for the EFA students I'm going to speak
about EFA because a couple of my kids um
actually leveraged that and we were
finally able to pass the the income
level and and be eligible um a lot of
students opt out to these tests so I
have three neurodiverse kids they would
be making designs out of the bubbles on
the paper I can tell you that much you
know and they're off the charts and
intelligence you know um a lot of kids
op out I'm going to leave you with some
statistics from gtown um actually
there's 211% it says with a disability
in the student body of about 2,000
students and 60% of them took the
alternative standardized test but but
only 60% so where's the other 40 is what
I would ask um your time is okay let me
wrap it up by just asking you to look at
these stats when you get a chance just
from one district and ask ask yourself
if this is actually providing value is
is this worth $2.5 million or do we
already have a way to prove learning
we're showing 50% proficiency on gostone
and year-over-year we're actually
declining so I would ask is this the
best use of our money and our time and
putting these students through this I
ask you humbly to reject and oppose this
Bill thank you thank you very much
represent Cordell do want to answer a
question you yeah thank you uh for
taking my question question we've had
several homeschool parents talk about um
having children with um special needs
yeah and you said you had three and um
we've heard very often that really for
parents with children with special needs
the only place that there can be
advancement um and learning for those
children is in a public school where
they can get the services how are your
children making out outside of the
public school they don't need Services
anymore they don't need those Services
they were not adding value in fact one
of the services actually told my son
that telling a white Li is actually okay
in speech therapy so those Services as
we got looking at them were not really
Services they were actually disservices
to us and you're able to provide these
things you can get them through your
insurance if you really need to go after
we did actually at one point use
occupational therapy but we did it
through our insurance we were able to
get hippotherapy for I actually had a
child very much like this lady in the
back who felt fell apart and he also
acquired a brain illness at the same
time I almost lost him but I was able to
do that through my insurance um there's
no other reason once we changed the
setting they didn't have the other
problems it was never a problem of
intelligence it was a problem of the
environment so we don't need we don't
need Services we're actually providing
you know we're going to create
independent adults who are already
preparing at 14 for college and they're
not going to be on the state St
so I would say you know not only is the
2.5 unnecessary but we're saving money
by allowing these students to meet the
eligibility requirements and have a
chance thank you thank you further
questions representative Tanner thank
you um do you have a school or it sounds
like or or are you talking about your
own children oh I'm talking about my own
children thank you it's not a bad idea
though thank
you any further questions from the
committee thank you very much thanks is
here welcome thank you good afternoon
I'm Chandler Gable I'm a homeschooling
dad from Manchester we traditional
unfunded homeschoolers and uh I urge you
to reject this bill uh at its core
homeschooling is about diversity I
believe that this bill puts that
diversity severely at risk I have two
boys they're 11 and eight currently
they're thriving using a classical uh
curriculum that teaches them math uh
Science History Latin writing and more
uh my oldest loves putting together
engineering projects he's learned to
build his own bookcase um he's uh he you
know he writes a great essay and both he
and my youngest are very interested in
owning their own business so I've got
them putting together business
plans what I want to emphasize is that
we wouldn't have time to do all this
with them if we were also forced to
teach to a test if there's a
standardized test that they have to take
at the end of the year that's going to
determine whether we can continue
homeschooling them we won't have time to
do these wonderful things that that are
so meaningful and so beneficial to them
um I also want to point out that my
program looks nothing like the uh
homeschooling program of some of my
friends and that's okay you know it's
just one beam of light in this Broad and
diverse rainbow that is uh you know wide
enough to Encompass the unique needs of
every child I respectfully ask that you
that you do not uh stifle that rainbow
under the CP atoned svenness of
standardized testing thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee I'm not seeing thank you very
much thank you I'm going to go through
the cards that I have here in front of
me H Hannah at G
York Emily
Elliott uh Rihanna Valley
Lisa
Cody and Jody a we've had problems
s and is that kayn left I don't have any
other pink cards up here is there
somebody you want me to go see if there
are people it's announced it's announced
no no it's announced they they should
know that
that um anybody else who wants to
testify in in the room right now then
I'm going to close this hearing for 10
1610 and thank everybody that remains
for listening to all this and I
coming